all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibontas thai guy
travis on that thursday evening destiny
campfire how are we doing gentlemen hey
bonds let's start with you how we do it
doing good uh i'm excited because i
finished dark souls one
uh completely ended up with like a plus
15 weapon
and
did i didn't do the dlc which is fine i
read about some of the dlc and honestly
it's like sad since after i had to fight
sif and everything so
guys you're not nervous though yeah i
was like it's cool but got to experience
dark souls 1 so i played demon souls 1
or demon souls dark souls 1 dark souls 3
sakura bloodborne neo-1 neo2 like this
is all of them and elden ring is finally
my time so that one i'm going to be
streaming most of the weekend like
friday after missouri video and then
saturday nothing but i'll ring until i
can't see straight that is my goal
and i'm really excited i literally
booted up last night just to check to
see and actually just patched it
yesterday night as well so it should be
running a little better so i booted up
just to see what it looked like ran
around the tutorial area real quick
while i was like recording and streaming
made sure everything looked good smooth
so i'm like
insanely pumped for tomorrow because
i've basically only seen a couple bits
here and there on twitter seems to
mostly be the opening area
and i'm 99 blind going in and i'm
thoroughly excited so that's where i'm
at oh yeah which platform just curious
before you pass on bc yeah i'll be
playing it on steam he's on pc yeah yeah
it's like being able to just it if a
game is available on pc for me to be
able to record stream and everything
it's not like consoles that difficult
but it's just all in the same platform
like honestly for something like this
i've
i should have enough hardware to play it
how i want to which is the exciting part
but the five second after going
literally from dark souls one turning it
off in the same day and then turning on
elden ring for five seconds i was like
oh 60 frames crispiness like it doesn't
even feel remotely the same so yeah i'm
pumped travis what about you man i know
i think i know what you've been doing
yeah what have you been doing my elden
ring uh journey has been hilarious
because i'm also doing it 100 blind i'm
80 hours in and i haven't killed a
single main boss
or done any of the main areas i've i've
been doing everything in my power i'm
level 120 and i've done nothing
productive in the game i've killed like
70 bosses but none of them are like
important all the side stuff that i hear
about yeah anytime anytime somebody
tells me to go somewhere i'm like no i
don't i don't wanna like i just don't
wanna i don't
want somebody telling me what to do so
it's been really funny but i am getting
to the point where it's like all right
travis you should probably do something
in the main story because you're running
out of things to do but i feel like i
haven't even played the game yet in 80
hours then but uh yeah this week i've
been um catching up on destiny uh and
i'm i'm working on a game review that
goes live next wednesday which is uh
tiny tina's wonderlands
so almost almost all the way through
that and that is basically like yeah
borderlands 3 i think styling and
probably maybe an engine update but
truly a standalone on its own right
yeah it is a standalone but it's based
off of the dlc for borderlands 2
where it's like a dnd board game and so
it's got lots of references to tabletop
gaming and it's got a more fantasy vibe
and a very clear like fourth wall
breaking even more than borderlands
usually breaks the fourth wall so um
it's pretty funny uh but yeah enjoying
that so far have the review up next week
and uh it's been busy man it's a it's
been it's been a busy couple of days you
guys catch that that harry potter thing
we oh
yeah
yeah
yeah
talk about that in the end because yeah
yeah yeah definitely want to talk about
that in the end that was quite cool
what do you mean lots of exciting stuff
going on yeah oh tons of exciting stuff
yeah um yeah just been dusty man been
the grind getting back into it just
doing the minutia the builds um right
now i'm just i'm having so much fun with
void 3.0 it's ridiculous in pve and just
being with volatile rounds and wells all
day and doing other stuff got to uh raid
with travis and has some interesting
funny hilarious boys
with driving the crew
sign call outs and people really bad
crew really very motley bunch of of
chiefs or you know it's funny
i let the chiefs talk it out right
because it's clear that there's not
consistency and i can but what's funny
the best part of it is hearing travis's
frustration rise like i said
here's the thing you know it's bad when
cog and i are in the party and neither
of us are talking because everyone else
is fighting i have never seen you quiet
that is actually we were quiet shocking
everybody else was talking over each
other about the best strategy and and
the cog
was fine he was just chilling but cog
was also only there for like one fourth
of the raid i was there the whole time
so i had to like watch this thing
unravel i i had just unraveled over the
time i was like dude there's this is
like easy like we've all know what to do
you guys are all fighting over oh here's
the best way to do the most dps i'm like
guys we're we're not beating the
encounter because you guys are fighting
and i was yeah it was really bad
it was great
terrible raid group terrible
we'll get into the story stuff and all
that but look we we got a very uh
special guest oh yeah we gonna get into
that story stuff you got a very special
guest who's been patient through all our
banter eve indeed wait so let's bring
him into the campfire welcome to the
last word episode number 189
this week lord saladin was in rare form
as we got to see one of his best moments
in destiny yet and the future of iron
banner is intriguing to say the least to
discuss all things gaming and destiny
this week we have a gentleman joining us
from the land of royalty the united
kingdom this man has been gaming longer
than many of us have been alive because
i assume many of you don't even know
what in television even means
in his early years he was a platformer
extraordinaire but it's been nearly all
destiny since that journey started back
in rise of iron a legend in the sherpa
community with over a thousand grand
master clears and countless raid carries
he is a master of pve and has the seals
all of the seals to prove it while he
may rage loudly when he plays crucible
and i mean really loudly he got to
legend comp as a solo player so you know
he can click heads when pressure is on
so let's welcome a man who has been to
ibiza so many times they know him by
name can cut a serious rug on the dance
floor has the most epic call outs from
his practices in the bingo hall and his
list of celebrity cameos for his merch
spots is rather impressive he is the
creator of the care home clan for the
old people die hard fan of manchester
city
freehand graffiti artist in his off time
and likely drinking some oasis in
between wipes during another raid carry
coming off what is likely another
12-hour stream and fits perfectly into
the campfire as both a titan and a
warlock the one the only granddad gaming
how you doing sir
look at that can we understand
we each have a program in the uk called
this is your life
oh how i felt lied i was brilliant yeah
i'm doing very good very good
definitely one of ease best right there
man good to have you at the destiny care
fire look it's always refreshing as an
older gentleman myself it's always
refreshing to have someone you know that
we could talk about some consoles and
stuff so i got to get right into it man
you got some some classic history about
you know talking from the from the
arcade days and then commodore 64 and
all that good stuff so like
back then you know what what was just i
was just curious about what kind of just
drove you to gaming was it the arcade
scene first or kind of was it like the
commodores the ataris the colecos and
all that kind of stuff first
yeah it was in television first well i
like he mentioned and that was just
basically
my dad brought one home one night and uh
i just remember getting really into this
game
called uh lock and chase which was
it it was sort of like a pac-man
yeah yeah and i remember like clearly
getting getting to a certain level after
after playing it for
uh beating me sister on it that was the
main
reason i was enjoying it because i was
better than her after saying she was
four years older
i remember getting to this this like
this level in it and everything sort of
changed and i can't remember if it was a
boss that came out or something
but the colors changed
on the screen it felt special do you
know what i mean
and then
after that yeah it was like hanging
around with mates and
going to the arcade and
then uh
playing games like 95 2 ghosts and
goblins yep i remember those real dark
souls
yeah that's all evil game seriously yeah
dragon's lair as well i always remember
that but i could never work it out
it was just like it was cartoon graphics
but
you just wrote in them days you just
wanted to jump on and you know
get right into it but i think with
dragon's lair you have to sort of be you
have to like read things you know and
actually
sort of react to stuff and it was it
wasn't for an 11 year old me that
definitely not
uh
but then how many raid completions do
you have in lock and chase
how many were hot
how many raid conclusions
a lot's going to say hello i haven't got
a clue
can you imagine
yeah yeah
i i did go back and watch on youtube
there's a
lock and chase through
and
i was i was searching for that bit that
i can still remember in my mind's eye
but i was searching for and i thought
this isn't changing so i don't know what
actually happened
uh but i can i can definitely remember
something changing in the game after i'd
got to a certain level but i watched
that play through and i couldn't find it
so
uh
but yeah i i can remember completing jet
set willie that was okay that was it
that was a big one
and the thrill of being in the arcade as
well and getting your high score on
there oh yeah yeah you're gonna have
everyone to see but you can only put
three letters in yes
uh
what are your guys's tags let's let's
hear let's hear some initials what do
you guys do obviously cog you probably
do cog right actually yes it was
far back
cognito yeah yeah cog didn't exist at
that uh so i think it was like b
and then zo or something like it was
some weird three i think i was probably
it was like bzo i used to always go with
that nice but what would your three uh
letter scores what would you go away
traveling
yeah i probably did like initials so or
something this was like e and
who knows what but yeah i was like i
don't think i was too creative at that
point i wasn't doing like
anything stupid like you know ass or
anything that would fit there there's
not too much that goes there i mean
people like there's jokes where you get
multiple scores and try and build words
but no i never got too creative i was
probably too too much of a goodie two
shoes when i was younger so ah
yeah
uh lil for little jay
that was my lady nice i was into bray
dancing as well so make me like
is about graffiti but then this is it's
a culture it's a life that is it's more
to it i don't know if some people go as
deep with it so when he said that i'm
like oh he's official he's really about
yeah he's head spinning for sure
yeah yes
the reason i got into the graffiti was
that uh i was i was quite good at break
dancing and uh
i attempted this uh move one day and it
was
i was like laying me back and then my
two mates had me legs and then he
flipped me over and i spun in the air
like backwards
but i landed wrong and landed on on the
back of my neck
uh
and the bottle just went as we could say
over here i just after that i was too
scared i'll try try moves and stuff and
because it was like four main
yeah four main uh calls to hip-hop he's
like they're bray dancing talking i'm
seeing talk dj in talked about the uh
other defeats yeah that's hip-hop right
there wow
this is like keeping it real goes wrong
i couldn't uh i couldn't dj i thought
graffiti yeah that's for me and i cuz i
quite like the danger of it as well
because in them
days weren't supposed to be at certain
places doing certain things
by the underground little certain yeah
little kids cross
little spots in london
yeah
i cause my parents a lot of a lot of
hearing
so you are banksy is that what we're
wearing here today oh i don't know no no
no no i don't use stencils
the word is still out on him being
banksy we we don't know for sure
i would say that one now that i'm not
him but yeah banksy's uh he's not liked
in the uh graffiti
matt the graffiti like culture that i
come from because
he's there's a lot of things that have
gone on with him and a lot of like uh
he's gone over a few pieces of
uh
like historical graffiti in in london so
there was a big sort of
like battle between him and uh another
graffiti is called robbo he was called
king robbo and that all blew up in like
the 20 20 50 26.
was that was when uh social media first
started because we all you know we all
forgot about everyone and each other
like
you can't understand when the graffiti
movements died down a little bit it was
sort of 1988 yeah all these all these
kids you grew up with and i was in a
crew called mtv which was stood for uh
more than vandals if we were doing legal
stuff but if we were doing the illegal
stuff we changed it to mad transit
vandals
a double
a worldwide crew
uh we had members in all over europe in
america in australia but then when we
all stopped doing graffiti we all we
never heard from anyone and then
facebook was invented and suddenly these
graffiti groups started popping up and
we all got back in such it was
the night that's cool then i started
doing it again because i've not painted
for 20 years and i did that as a job but
not not graffiti yeah so
it was good to get back into it it's one
of those fair moments where like social
media actually had a cool moment where
you know people had fallen apart and
then finally actually got to reconnect
but that's actually
that's yeah it sounds like you you
people could sit down and just listen to
story time with uh granddad gaming over
here so
for sure oh yeah oh yeah
you got e
uh well yeah i mean you kind of got into
the graffiti stuff that was gonna be my
question so the next piece i guess goes
into um
just like how i mean
so you obviously graffiti was a big
thing but you took a break and it sounds
like the same thing happened in gaming
that you you know into all the older
consoles platformers super mario world
like all the older ones and then there
was this like break from
basically it sounds like snes almost to
was it like xbox and crackdown and
division and there's this break in there
what is there anything specific that
made you like stop gaming you know if
there was any cool stuff besides all the
crazy stuff you just described in the
middle and then also like what
kind of pulled you back in was it
someone was it a game was just like
picked one up and kind of tripped into
it how did that gaming transition go on
both ends
well
what made me stop mainly was uh
i discovered
ladies
i discovered nightclubs that's the best
answer i've heard on this one
there's a very cool discovery like what
happened i came to the age
i came from the age of puberty
yeah
it's a pretty good
yeah i discovered the the uh the head in
this life maybe and also i had a child
very young as well
so yeah i had like
so i sort of like when he was born i
calm down a bit but then when me and his
mother split up i end up going back out
and partying and stuff but i think my
party is mainly because of the job i had
as well because the advertising industry
in the uh 90s it was not for the faint
hide
you know what i mean you used to work
hard and play really hard as well so uh
i can remember you'd be you know you'd
finish on a on a friday night or
whatever time and then you'd be lucky if
you got to sleep again until you know
from sunset till sunday so
yeah i didn't have time for gaming but
then
what happened was uh
i had a little bit of an accident and i
was in i was in hospital for
it was about
four weeks five weeks something like
that and uh
my friend had been bugging me to get an
xbox and i was like i'm not i'm not
playing games games are for kids
cal plays games i don't know what i'm
not playing games uh but then when i
came out of hospital i couldn't go back
to work straight away
uh i thought you know what i'm going to
get myself an xbox but i'm sorry i'm
doing nothing
and the rest is history
wow women weren't an option you came
back to me yeah yeah i couldn't believe
it honestly i was like this is brilliant
oh yeah like if you hadn't touched it
just that long yeah that's probably a
huge transition super mario yeah xbox
yeah yeah i couldn't believe it and like
when red dead redemption when i uh
i had me first go online in that i
couldn't believe that i could hear other
people and
because uh
you had a
proximity in in that so you could
certainly hear people and at first it
made me jump you know what i mean
[Laughter]
what's funny is red dead redemption i
believe is the sequel to lock and chase
so you really didn't miss much exactly
yeah you got the exact follow-up there
there you go yeah
what you got for
let's talk about destiny
um so you've been out of the you've been
out of the game for a while out there
just uh just to tearing it up in the the
world of ladies so that's great uh good
for you
um well you know some of us are still
working toward it really
i was actually just trying to get cog to
choke on his drink to be honest
[Laughter]
so so you come back and uh it sounds
like you probably missed the whole
advent of the shooter genre so you
missed quite a quite a bit of of that
you know the shooter genre didn't really
exist when you started playing games and
then all of a sudden it's here so what
drew you to destiny uh
presumably not having a relationship
with bungie beforehand or having played
any halo games it sounds like you missed
probably a lot of those
times yeah so so
what was your what was your kind of
gateway drug to destiny or how did you
get lead there it was division i was
a meta
yeah yeah i was playing division i got i
got really into division like the builds
and everything and
uh
i was doing the uh one of the incursions
which are like mini raids oh yeah uh in
division called dragon's nest i think he
was called sounds right yeah
and on lfg i met this uh this guy who
i'm still in the clan with now
and uh he invited me to an xbox party
and
he's
he was he was doing so much damage to
the bosses and he he gave me advice on
builds and stuff
and uh this this little perking division
called damage to elites
and uh i remember it's clear as day i
met i met him on the on the wednesday
night and i was going to a beef that the
next day
and i i remember thinking [ __ ] i hope
he's still around when i get back yeah i
can learn a lot from him about you know
about builds and stuff
anyway come back from a beefer and yeah
he's still there as soon as i went
online he sends me a party request and
uh
so it's quite a long story short once
i'd been once was done with division and
it was going through a bit of a bit of a
slow patch
uh he said have you ever tried destiny
and it was
just before rise of iron came out
so we had the the destiny the collection
so we've got everything all all the uh
all the expansions plus rise of iron but
rise of iron was still two weeks until
it was uh
released yes i remembered it
yeah so i had like taken king to go
through uh house of wolves all that sort
of stuff
and uh
yeah that's what helped me really i just
i think division got me into looter
shooters and
destiny stole me
that was uh basically what happened
but i did have a brief stuff up stop off
uh with warframe i put so many hours
into that nice okay it's a great game uh
yeah brilliant brilliant if i'd still
play it now probably if there was uh
cross save between xbox and pc
because now i'm on pc i'll
i will go back to xbox i did for a
little while but
crosstalk would do it's not an easy
thing i get but crosstalk would do a lot
of games a lot of good too as you just
said right there like you would jump in
every software to make it like maybe a
one day stream if you could just pick up
where you left off and not have to start
over because warframe is nothing but
hours so there's no way yeah you want to
do that again yeah
mastery ranked 28 i got two one
which
was
quite high at the time that was that
high she could get into i think is uh i
think he can get higher now well he can
do but uh the there is they are supposed
to be doing it it was supposed to happen
with this latest
uh expansion but for some reason it
didn't happen but i think it will happen
this year
they'll be uh become cross save our
cross play yeah oh yeah they need it
they have a lot of pc exclusives though
like and the time the calendar of
content for pc i think it's
eight weeks in front of console so
straight away you've got
you've got issues there but
that's uh that's for digital extremes to
serve out in it
you need indeed no doubt no doubt that
you're getting into destiny so like
you're playing the so i'm assuming you
get the collection you're playing in
sequence i'm i'm gonna assume right from
yeah you know going from regular then
you know probably um was it uh what was
the crota expansion the dark below right
the curtis end crosstalk below right
right
was the raid
and then you got you know what you're
doing
was harrison oh well like all that good
stuff but um yeah what was the moment so
osiris
so like what was the moment
i want to say whether it be
gameplay-wise whether it be a dungeon a
raid i mean i'm assuming not pvp based
on your history but like what was the
moment where you like okay
i love this game like i i this is the
game for me like what was it what was
the activity what were you doing take me
back
rough of the machine
it's uh even
even the outbreak quest way up to
you know do the uh
stuff
i was just i this is amazing because
obviously division at
it was
with division it was always some sort
there was always like that limitation
wasn't it because it was real life yeah
because it was exactly it was like
humans you weren't you shooting the guy
in the hoodie twelve times we knocked
slammer
yeah yeah
blokes are walking about with bigger
fire things on the back shooting fire
out you know normal life yeah
i'm saying for sure yeah i'm gonna know
that there's someone out there
so we can see some fire no but you know
what i mean so
like uh
just the graphics and everything and
obviously not the storytelling of
destiny because i was never
even though i got max grimoire i think i
got max queen wow on destiny one
yeah yeah i think he did but i wasn't
even though i've got all the books i
didn't delve into the law that much it's
only recently i've started getting into
the law
since witch queen because that grabbed
me i thought yeah i was always wanting
to skip the uh
skip the cutscenes he didn't interest me
i know i know
but
i don't blame you i was like you know
what d1 storytelling was a different
animal than d2 you skip again you skip
them this week i'm gonna be mad at you
you skip them back then no no
that that i won't hold too much against
you
i think since splicer since
maybe maybe four stops skipping them i
sort of knew what was going on but
it was only sort of half an hour and now
i've got two eyes on it because i think
it's brilliant yeah really
it's come a long way
yeah some of them cut scenes for
witchcraft
and i've got i'm not i'm known to have a
spring in a swinging brick as a heart
you know what i mean i don't get
emotional either and that made the uh
the old hairs on their back of me neck
stand up some of them cut scenes the one
where she was dying and she just drops
down on the edge yeah
that cliff is yeah that's yeah
that's an epic one
did you feel sorry for a bit though
because i did i was like yeah that's i
don't know how many things i still feel
sorry for her yeah i mean i feel like
she's she didn't get a chance yeah yeah
she's
misunderstood yeah and then like micro i
feel i feel like the only person who
understands her is the traveler i i feel
like the traveler was like no you know
what everybody gets a shot at redemption
like that's what becoming a guardian is
it erases all the past but she her fatal
sin was that she
she organized her
memories to come back to her so that she
could continue being the worst so
uh yeah she
she kind of failed her shot at
redemption but yeah yeah too bad
yeah
so right you'll be back we need to get
you ready yeah so
the chat is asking before i pass it back
to e all the chat is asking we have to
ask you that you must rank at least for
now your top three raids
go ahead franchises yeah no full frame
like d1 and d2 you can go both sides so
yeah right uh wrath of the machine i
think number one
number two deep stone crypt nice wow
and
number three
i don't know though is deep stones
deep stone crips
third third
i'd have to go
out king's fall
oh oh you don't broke day hearts today
is it last minute i agree
i think the new one maybe the new one is
third okay okay he's back yeah
but do what is am i just saying for the
machine because it's nostalgia
are
orders yeah can i ask why not that deep
soul is a bad rate this is the first
time i've ever seen half deep stone with
that love not that it's a great raid
what was the moment for you that really
took it
into that top three for you
i think because mainly because it was
the first one that sherpa had so many
people through i think i've got
emotional attachments
and that's when i sort of like
may i don't like to say made me name but
where it
it i sort of like met so many people
sure that raid
come to the channel on people i'm still
friends with
uh
so i think it's more of an emotional
attachment the actual
raid i think i think he's just got
everything as well i think it's
yeah it's got a decent boss fight at the
end
it's uh even though you are stood still
it is
the uh
the jumping puzzle is great the uh
i think a tracks is really
really well done i think yeah i think
he's just yeah yeah i think he's a cool
wrestler and i also think deep stone
[ __ ] has the best journey like the fact
that you start on this wait frozen
wasteland and then you go up into space
as part of the story and then you crash
back down like you hold that's the
journey that you go on in that rating
it's so cool
yeah
last wish if there wasn't for the riven
driven cheese i think i'd last wish
would be
up there
yeah i think it'd be up there yeah
because i think i'll spoil say i wish
you'd fix that sooner
but i wasn't playing destiny 2 when last
which was uh
last wish was released so again with
deep stone that was one of the first uh
oh no this crown of sorrow
i love crabbing the sorrow as well oh
there we go there's the spicy taste
really yeah first it's very spicy yeah
spicy i've only done i've only done that
red like four times yeah i don't know as
soon as i get this weapon i'm out of
here
the beginning was
what if it wasn't for that beginning in
the beginning that would be
probably
be my favorite because i loved that
bathroom and the fact that and and the
jumping puzzle in that as well you have
to you know i mean shooting things
to make the
the other uh platforms come up it was
challenging even though most people used
to cheese at a crossbow yeah
i think that raid is terrible
[Applause]
yeah that joke's going strong tonight
but that's fine
granddad jokes
yeah crown of sorrow actually i think
me three favorites i think uh
see ya
i picked from you stone crypts on crips
it's a real selfie's choice for him i've
never seen someone make such a labored
decision yeah so but i mean he's
he's a big raider so that's like i get
it it's cool like and i like i love it i
like how everybody i honestly
the fact that deep stone crypts people
can
the reason why you peak deep stone [ __ ]
makes perfect sense the emotional
attachment the journey that you've been
through with however many guardians
you've taken through that thing the way
you know it the way you've taught it and
as you said it's a cool journey to go
through and the fact that you've been
through it with so many people i totally
100 get why it's up there so
that makes perfect sense
well
anything else we want to uh ask this man
about the desk i gotta know uh titan or
warlock
if you have to pick one right now which
one do you pick
careful be careful
i think in the present oh no because two
hours of the week and i i really enjoyed
i was going to say titan but
you're doing well you're doing well go
with your heart and speak speak from the
heart
i think
one i can't play any other ever again
yeah that's yeah i
could only pick one moving forward
warlock
there you go
educate educate everyone you know
why
class why are you great people why
people people pick the easy path
people are weak you can do anything on a
wall account you can support
but since yesterday
we're a lot more than a lot more than
support
with that devour and uh the old child of
the old gods child of the old guard baby
i got kills in trials at weekend just
because of that which out which i'll be
the youngest thing yeah yeah all you
have to do is like throw an axe put your
rift down throw an action ball down the
middle lane
get a few tags and it's
like the good guys finish them off you
know these are decent people travis's
soul right now and i love it because it
all feels easy and he hates that and
it gives me joy when he's upset
it's uh it's the new shattered stuff
i'm a titan and you know warlocks can do
anything that's fair except for winner
crucible match or guardian games but
they can do uh you know most things
guardian games will give you that's
that's funny yeah man
but it's one of those things though when
i sit there and i'm
working on trying to solo
the master version of vox obscura and i
want to go void because it has all the
new benefits from the subclass and
everything but when i go to like think
about using my super it's either a
bubble for some damage for my weapon and
i'm just like if i could just throw a
nova bomb right now
the amount of dps output you get in your
one button push is crazy as opposed to a
bubble or have to try and shield bash a
guy and survive just that one like just
that one button push for nova bomb is
yeah and just nukes the guy for a little
while i'm like yeah that would be really
beneficial but don't have that one so
i do feel like
i don't know it was like all classes
definitely have their pieces to it but
the fact that you were half warlock and
half titan and you were that divided
anyway you already fit in with the
podcast yeah you were good yeah yeah
you were you weren't a hunter so yeah
you're already fine oh damn
what's going to happen with solar though
when solar gets uh
yeah
i can't wait to see what i'm saying i
want to see what our hammers do
when they fix the big
sledgehammer yeah they have to do
something good with that because that
has been so bad for so long i hope solar
3.0 makes that makes that one fun
because if they don't give that love i'm
gonna be real sad
yeah
yeah one of these light updates has to
give titans a good subclass yeah please
i was like void feels pretty good for a
titan like the overshield is strong
no question that strong and you put
overshield on with like sightings and
pvp you can get annoying
um but just like the power i want the
the arc and the solar the power output
those are the two i'm waiting on and
those are those are where titans really
get to shine for dps and those just
aren't here yet balling star
i forgot you know about the void yeah
titan because in the inval that's why
i've been running all the time he's
titan
and the uh but the shield bash is uh i
know i know it's always at the shield
bash but it just feels different now
yeah with the overshield and pve with
the like void bat shield bash overshield
on you explosions on them feels good it
really does feel good so yeah
no i think you uh you passed that
question with flying colors good job
we asked him his least favorite raid is
that fair yes no we don't usually do i
like that that's a great question
because you said crown's your one of
your favorites so now i have to know
what your least good point
probably be
well not probably is garden but
okay really i still like it i still like
it but i just don't like
it can always go so wrong i've had some
horrible experiences in that raid but
i've had some good good experiences too
but when
when you're taking new people through
that oh any more than two ah
yeah people talk about divinity
people don't like doing divinity sherpas
because they're always a nightmare but
they're only a nightmare because people
because of that bus stage by that time
you've done all the puzzles
so it's not the divinity quest it's
because you're taking new people through
that yeah
it's uh i'm with you bro yeah
a lot of cooperation
yeah remember number one
sorry god no i'm just gonna say
especially the congo line you gotta all
line up and then hit the thing and then
somebody runs the wrong spot and again
it gets pulled oh my god and then when
you're like okay we need someone to
rebuild the plate and get because you
know that he's taking the floor away
it's just for the for a new you made a
good point for for more than one new
person at a time yeah as a sherpa that
rate can be challenging yeah yeah i
think my record i think he was six hours
i think
taking i think it was three just for the
last encounter
oh no that was the full raid six hours
of the whole raid but yeah half of the
crew knew yeah that's yeah but it would
have been five and a half hours on the
last encounter if it's because the rest
of it's quite simple in there but yeah
it's just like you can
uh people will be trying to build and
then you come out of the uh come out the
portal to bank your moats but you get
tethered because they're trying to build
and it's like then you can't shoot and
you oh
before you know it it's a way
oh yeah a lot of things that can do but
at least i don't think we've we've
talked about our least favorites on this
this chat uh between us yeah e
why me first
why does that seem fair notice it's a
trap
question you know mine's already travis
do you know yours
oh yeah what is it
spire stars
that is the correct answer i i hate that
raid i hate it so much because because
here's the thing it's not that
interesting of a raid and if it were
like crown of sorrows i would have just
done it four times and been done when i
got terrible but not only does it not
really have an interesting loot i had to
do it 50 times because it had an emote
i could not get it to draw every person
i did it with would do it
get it on the first drop the first drop
when you're just getting into the raid
everybody would get it on there and i
did it 50 plus times and could not get
that damn emo i have almost every emote
in the game like it's so it was a
sticking point with me it was and it's
the coolest one at the time especially
yeah i was like i have to get it and and
i just could not get it to drop so yeah
aspire stars dude i i i did not like
that with you i'm with you um same thing
i i just it didn't really have a story
i'm like who is cal or what is he doing
here yeah you know what i mean and then
like like you said i was forced because
i'm such a sleeper fanboy and the only
way you could get that catalyst at the
time
was to do that
horrible frame
i just did like i guess you know what i
just the last especially the last
encounter was kind of in the same room
do it twice but yeah it was i was forced
to do a raid i didn't want to do and
that's just the end of it but e i'm
curious what is your
least i mean i think it's between one of
these two that you guys are both
mentioning because crown the only couple
of times i did it
it's just yeah they didn't do anything
special at all because i mean leviathan
i still like it has some unique new
tools no it's not low i'm saying
leviathan has some has some good sides
you've got
what the hell is the other raid lair uh
not crown but what's the other one i
what was your element
of words was like
the bathroom was interesting it was
short but i think people enjoyed that
um but like i can see the garden part
especially on the sherpa side of things
but spire is pretty low i never i only
did it probably like a couple of times
like spire never did that much i didn't
i didn't farm for either of the things
these two are going for so
that i get and then but garden always
seemed
garden is like a weird one it just yeah
the whole line connections things to it
it's like when you eventually i went
through and i got like
hard sherpa for
like i knew the encounters but when it
came to divinity it was like people who
knew what they were doing they're like
all right stand here and do the little
dance and move and move the lines around
it was cool
but then when you get to the end yo
shout out real quick to jarv
big man on campus by the way uh shout
out to that man please go find that man
on twitter and youtube hit that
subscribe like and all those good things
um
another one over over there on your side
of the world there granddad yeah
yeah yeah he's my clan mate nice yeah
that's my guy
jarv's a good guy
but yeah it's it's probably between
those two because
mostly everything else i can think of
generally something that i tend to like
about them whether it be like even i'm
like crota's in like i like the thematic
nature of the hive and the frantic and
wrath and i don't hate vog
like it's not high but it's not low like
so it's like when it come yeah those
it's gonna be between one of those two
it's gotta be for me like i could
yeah so it's like i don't i don't have
any i don't know which one is worse but
i would say
neither of those are
those are gonna be fighting for the
bottom spot for sure yeah for
sure can i change my answer yeah yes i
actually forgot about spyware stars
i probably did garden 200 times maybe
maybe less maybe more but sparrow stars
i think i did one of the only raids that
is in single figures
again it's because i wasn't playing
around with that i wasn't single figure
i didn't go back to do it that much
leviathan i went back to to do
i think i ended up doing that 20 times
or something but
uh
it was yeah so yeah that would have to
have to be sparrow stars definitely no
no that is correct it's nice and it
looks so bad he forgot to include it as
his worst raid i mean do you need more
proof than that that's it that's what
you do when you try to erase it for your
memory yeah one of the funniest things
i go live i'm very spiteful now
when i see i play like a strike or
something and i see someone get the
sleeper catalyst as a drop
it burns by there's a there's a triumph
to get the emote which is the thing i
did the raid 50 times to get so they
added that later uh
i spent dozens of hours of my life
farming for that damn emo and now now
everybody gets it but you know what
everybody got on their first drop anyway
so was it any worse i destiny hates me
man this guy's a bungee i swear to god
they they hate me and have just marked
my account for death so shut up
no i was going to say a couple super
chats necromancer zale earlier on the
show finally got a cabal ally mission we
will talk about that wish there was more
to it yeah we're going to get to the
story and then also see if attack real
quick spire deserved to be sunset there
you go
that's my god
jarvis of king's fall forever so we got
we already got your answer so well right
john i love that rave yeah king's great
right
right
how many times
don't have it
i haven't tried as much but asked travis
how many times it took him
yeah so vex
vex mythic last is the one weapon that
seems to have a special connection with
me because i got it my first drop the
first day of all the glass came out when
i beat it
i got it and i got it my first drop the
first day vaulted glass came out in the
wow
i have like a special connection with
that one but every other one like yeah
uh the rocket launcher eyes of tomorrow
i think i did that one 80 times like the
anarchy took me like 50 times like all
of them and i still don't have the one
for the new raid not that it's been too
long but i have a feeling it's gonna be
one of those yeah
and then the casino chooses not to pay
out for anything else yeah yeah yeah is
it it's like youtuber look we go on
about it in our clan because i think jav
and houndish they both
got uh vex on the first couple of runs
and they've both got the new pulse rifle
as well on the first couple of here's
the thing i think i think vex has a
higher drop rate for people who who got
vex in d1 i swear it does because like
all the people that are ogs they got
their vex right away and the people that
didn't really do raids in d1 or at least
vex like they
you know they have trouble getting it
i'm just like there's something to it
it's like a
it's a time affinity weapon yeah it
could be because it took me 59 goals and
i didn't do
i uh yeah i think i think i only did it
once or twice a uh
vlog in the original destiny because i
came to it late when rough of the
machine came out so it wasn't i think
it's when they brought up the hard
version of it yeah but i never got
vexing d1
like i say i only did it a handful of
times
uh
like doing doing raids in the hundreds
is quite a new thing for me
since
since like dsc
garden
yeah it's like that was when i had my
original raid group in d1 vog and
my buddy i think almost filled out his
heavy slot with the
quantity of gal horns he had i think he
almost had nine before i got my first
galley so it's just like i've had crap
rng on red drops for
a while
so i don't tend to uh hope for that but
you know you yeah they're on the private
stream or network you can't tell
everybody about that jarv but yeah
that's the private servers where they
get their secret drops so
for sure well shout out to good destiny
raid rankings but we had a very very
cool story beat happen
this week so i do want to kind of jump
into that first before we talk about
like iron banner and some other things
um
which queen we got most of already we
got the vow of the disciple read
fantastic on both of those accounts so
far we've kind of definitely talked
about those plenty these are the reasons
risen has been slowly building had a
little bit of stories we got the one
from saladin previously with the you
know animated storyboard kind of going
through what his
you know test of mercy was previously
and now this week
it went
full
amazing story moment for saladin like i
never expected to see
him in this moment and
um
granddad i want to ask you first like
when you watched when you played through
season the risen the final story beats
this week for
psiops missions what was your take on
and just kind of if you want to tell
people just kind of what you saw happen
like what how did the story hit you and
what what did you see happen there
uh well first of all
i was just like crow crow come on yeah
we've
forgiven all your shite from the past
yes we've forgiven yeah
we're gonna do something stupid like
this why are you playing out loud you
know what i mean you'd give him a clip
round the air and
wait wait i felt sorry for the scion for
for a moment i was like
ugh what what are you doing
and yet this one feels like it hits hard
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like i said
earlier i've never been invested in
story like i am at the moment
like from from sort of like splicer time
i've got really into i've even started
watching lore videos and nice i never
thought i never thought i'd do do stuff
like that i wasn't interested i just
wanted to do raids and
you know shower
shower to scream when playing crucible
and i was happy you know what i mean i
wasn't bothered about the story but
yeah i think they're doing a really
really good job the narrative team they
take all the props i think
uh
yeah they've got me invested and when he
when he went over to kaitlyn she yeah
she's an amazing character yes she's
really really good yes she's
she's can't believe this is ready to
turn on that booty call he was ready man
he was ready to go yeah yeah i mean i
would i would entertain her definitely
his wife's number nine no
[Laughter]
i like it he's ready to turn on his boo
though he's built such a rapport with
her i like what he's doing i like what
jarv said though he's like was it me or
did anyone else want to see zavala
thunder crash title and i will say after
uh witch queen cinematic when he punched
the table and then now this one you see
the hand kind of start tingling i want
to see what it takes for zavala to
get unhinged i want to see him break
finally and i hope they ever do that to
a point where he is raw i hope they let
him have that moment because lance eric
would obviously nail it but i just want
to see them i want to see zavala let
loose because he's so
kept right now and i want to see the
point what it takes to break him
yeah i think he's the uh he's the
paragon he's the the immovable object
and i don't i don't think he'll break i
think that's that's got to be his
his arc what if like what about
[Music]
know yeah can i stand in defense of crow
because i think people are giving people
someone to hit this real hard time so
how could i put this i think that the
dreaming city is not the only thing that
sabathin cursed
and uh and i think that you we just got
done spending an entire campaign
learning
what happens when you're given a second
chance and you're unable to untether
yourself from the past
savathune
is basically an example of
somebody who got a second chance and
failed
failed to to make the most of it because
she repeated the same mistakes because
she insisted on learning who she was
right that that's basically her fatal
flaw she she could have actually been
redeemed i believe i i think it's there
i think it's in her character and i
think that that's what the traveler
believed too i think that's why the
traveler gave sabathune light um and
that didn't happen because she was too
uh
too uh untrusting to actually to give
herself that second chance and that
ended up being her undoing and i think
we're learning that like
once you learn who you are once you once
you cross that line as a guardian it
sort of dooms you and savathun did that
for crow and in in a sense crow wanted
it right but for all we know our
character is a monster too
but we don't we're not bound yeah we're
not bound to that history to that burden
and i think that seeing crow
fall prey to the same mistakes he made
because he he now has this this
history that no other guardians have to
deal with is a lesson that everybody
should be paying attention to because we
also see it happening with anna bray we
also see it happening with the gunsmith
we see it happening with these
characters that are getting closer to
the edge and i think that that's going
to be a problem in the future i think it
could end up because that it's the one
thing that that unites all the guardians
is that whatever whatever differences
they may have had in their past lives
none of that matters now because they've
been forced to put themselves aside and
become light bearers and i think that
once all that history and that
selfishness and that the past of of who
they were catches up with them i think
it becomes really hard to separate who
you are from
this sort of tool that you've been
forced to be turned into and so i think
uh i think the crow is getting a super
bad rap for for something that is
basically not his fault i mean savathun
sort of is to blame for this one and i
think that uh
we should
be paying attention to the pattern of
people
of people uh kind of falling and
becoming a problem once they once they
learn about their true history once
about their past so i i'm uh i'm super
empathetic and sympathetic toward the
crow and uh and think that
uh now i'm sort of worried about the
other people who have started to learn
about pieces of their history to be
honest i'm worried about like what the
gunsmith's gonna do like i'm kind of
worried about these characters now so
it's really interesting but but as as
you said uh grandad like uh i've never
been more interested in the lore and i
think the stuff they're doing is super
nuanced and interesting and uh and yeah
man i'm logging on every week happily
although it sounds like we're gonna be
taking a a pretty big hiatus here for a
while so we'll see yeah yeah that's my
take
what about you cog what was your i know
like for reactions and stuff i know it's
not you know saint and osiris and and
your boys i love everybody i know i know
but i was like i know but
uh how did this one hit you this week
excellent
excellent um world-class world-class
storytelling um
the fact
that this is going on
during an amazing
savathun campaign
brightpost is just a testament to where
the writing has gone it is so good
that the campaign that like you you
could make an argument in a weird way
that like season of risen is like so
much more interesting on some level on a
small level just because i want to know
where they go what they've done with
saladin i'm gonna be honest i've never i
liked the character
but he would get on my nerves i'm gonna
be like because the way i looked at it i
was team crowe
to this moment
this week to this week i was team crow
because crow used to call him out when
we used to do those other missions crow
would be like wait a minute you know now
that i'm a guardian when the red war
came
where was you where where why were you
always abandoning situations and silent
was he didn't really have a lot of good
retorts just like you know young buck
you know you don't know you know it was
always
the older guy talking to the younger guy
always stunning them like you don't know
but but crow make good points as a new
light right so
to me this week i'm sitting there and i
remember after the mission you go
through they're like where's where's
crow he's he's supposed to be the scout
like what's going on shout out to the
mission with the cabal actually fighting
with us that that was really really cool
the title battleground was yes
i've been doing the psyop battleground i
rushed to do them as soon as they come
out because i want to know what's going
on and i thought it was interesting how
they set it up because prior to that
tr like savala's getting all comfortable
i don't know if you caught this dialogue
and he's like you know this alliance is
really looking good and you know and
kind of like
relax
you know trust
needs to be built you know little man
like called out right so we get to this
moment and you come back to that helm
and you see what our boy has done and
this is the part i just he just lost me
on that one part cause i'm like
he's doing this bleeding heart stuff and
i'm like i get it from an ethical
standpoint
but this is war like the the hive are
here they're trying to we still have
zebra wrath we still got things to deal
with right so i'm like i get this
sentiment but you know better now the
whole alliance is in jeopardy with the
cabal that's why i'm like oh where this
is going to go
so the scene happens
and i'm not going for i was on the edge
of my seat i'm like okay because crow is
will i give crow this he was willing
because kaido was about to see he wasn't
going to take the l like yeah
kaido was like i don't care about all of
that
where are we from
for life
from i don't want it so you go figure it
out whose head is coming off today i'm
ready for the head chopping i love her
she was awesome right so he get there
and i can't front to travis's credit
crow step bar with the sheep his eye
shave his eyes the head down he ready
for the head to come off yeah i cannot
when saladin stepped up
goosebumps
it was such a character develop moment
and it it was it was earned because
prior to that he kept trying to tell him
stop making these rats decisions
everything has a consequence when you do
when you jump off on the cuff there's a
console what they're doing is so good
for crow's arc
to teach him this lesson and then the
fact that
you know zavala to his credit e
he was charging up oh yeah he was
like he's about to throw his
credit though or is that like him
putting
crow before the alliance yeah
all of humanity yeah trev he jeopardized
him he was about to jeopardize the
bishop and it basically it set up
saladin again
because prior to the conversation with
savala and saladin
sawala would mention like you know he
was always a wise influence because i
was always trying to get like why does
he respect silence so much sometimes and
i felt the this one was earned i'm like
okay i get it so he's willing to put his
head on the chop i'm sorry it's spoilers
you sorry you got to watch bra sorry
dallas you come on now it's week weekly
content but you know he put his head out
there and at the end of the day you know
i gotta respect him for that and i gotta
respect kaido
cause kylo was like you know what that
was gangster yeah
you
know from the cabal standpoint how we
move we ain't gonna kill you but you're
gonna be an indentured servant now
you're brock
that was amazing
yeah yeah i love the name too what's
funny is that actually helps you that
actually helps humanity it's kind of not
that much of a loss exactly it means
yeah exactly we've got someone on that
board now yeah yeah they're thinking
about like zavala and that relationship
with crow that you're right you know
that could that could be troubling if if
he
because that's like usually like he said
before survival has done his
level-headed immovable object and that
showed
that
he was about to sit when he yep
you know it's like well crow
what was it was it season of the chosen
where was it crow who tried to save him
basically
yeah so he's trying to save him from
that and they have like you know to
reach the handout moment which is the
difference from the shooting and then
you come back and have now zavala about
to step in for him and then it's like
who's gonna save the day zavala's
teacher saladin the one who taught him
you know to be who he is and obviously
who's been there and then salad knew
it's like what's the best thing you can
do for the alliance between cabal and
the humanity he's gonna step in
save the alliance like do that now he's
on the war cancel now he's bracus forge
and you've got zavala and crow still
building up what like you know father
and son relationship they kind of have
slowly butting up to be whatever they're
gonna be i don't know if crow is ever
gonna be justified to be the hunter
vanguard though
i know a lot of people see him going
there but i don't know if he's
ever gonna be in a right enough state to
fit that role it doesn't seem like
that's where he should be he doesn't no
he's already got enough going on in the
head he's already been through enough
he's got old memories new memories and
everything
i mean zavala was about to prediction
there but and then you've got icora
who's just you know the pillar of
i'm i'm completely stable until i'm
gonna nova bomb your ass but outside of
that like
crow does not fit the hunter van garden
i don't think he should go i would
rather see anna bray go into that spot
even though i don't know if she belongs
there but i don't see crow fitting that
spot but now
it's not like hey here's this crow story
that's been built up and we're going to
chop his head off and move on and take
the life but still maintain the alliance
that's now you've got this avalanche
crew who can be together they're going
to talk with salad and on the on the
comms between the war council and have
all this stuff working on so i'm
i'm excited that they maintained crow as
a character
but again i think as you said travis you
actually said it pretty well that he's
he deserves a little more credit than we
give him with everything going on in his
head and i like the way you phrased that
which is good yeah it was good though i
mean like if crow would have fought his
feet he could have said
uh well
the reason i got rid of that scion
reason i did that he was the one who
tried to kill isabella i recognized him
you know from that he could he could
have done a bit of a fancy footwork
i have to do it boss did you guys know
do you even know who the scion was
though
the scion what is one of kaido's oldest
friends
yes
but one of kaido's kind of oldest
friends as well so the fact that that's
the scion who died was kind of like yeah
something's happening so the fact is
the fact that she forgave him forgave
the whole situation when
salad and stepped up was even bigger due
to the weight of who he she lost
and did you catch
how bungie is narratively going to
affect iron banner oh yeah well i was
getting there but yeah absolutely yeah
yeah she's got she's got some ideas
banner but kyle's coming in to make some
modifications i guess that'll be
interesting yeah
to your point i hear where you're going
i'm not saying you're wrong you as of
right now
crow is not ready to do that
my prediction
is they're building him up to some type
of heroic moment where he's going to
earn it that's what i'm going to predict
right now i think he's been through a
lot and travis is right his mind said he
he's going through what few guardians
have to go through which is knowing your
former self knowing the horrific stuff
you did but the way they're doing this
it's almost like a rite of passage and i
think saladin was the correct choice for
this like he gave his life in you know
indentured servitude i think right now
still that moment's not enough i'm with
you e yeah but i think later whether it
be lightfoot something cataclysmic is
happening my prediction
is he's gonna do something awesome and
we're gonna go
oh
okay that that that's what i'm rolling
with right now we'll see if it plays let
me see if we can get about three years
to see if that pays off so we'll just
put a pin in that one yeah shout out
real quick again to necromancer with the
five dollar super chat this season
really built the story for the cabal
alliance of the four alien races i like
the cabal the most
ready for more on the vex next yeah the
cabal have been very interesting the
fallen we keep seeing the houses and
stuff and we got myth racks which is
cool but just the cabal being a faction
of war and the ships and the honor that
they have between them and it was going
through
uh i think it was going through the
psyops battlegrounds when you're in the
moon and they're saying this is a lot to
be thrown no i think it's actually vox
obscura they're like man they're
throwing a lot at us and it's like well
the scale of the forces we have to throw
at you is basically a sign of respect
from the cabal
the stronger you are the more we have to
basically like throw back at you so it's
like if they have a huge force thrown at
you it's they respect you so it's a it's
a weird culture and it's very war based
obviously but it is it is one of the
more interesting ones we've had just the
way they kind of brought the cabal out
of nowhere to be yeah there are these
people kind of mostly who are on mars
and stuff too one of the coolest groups
that we have now it's nice to see a turn
for this race
just how big they are as well
just
just the size of kyle and the size of
them scions in that uh michigan
when they finally combined together that
was the first time we saw one that big
and now
yeah the ones we see in this
battlegrounds are that same size and
they're huge
yeah
is that based on like their uh rank how
big they are do you think
so this is something i've always
wondered about destiny and i feel like
they have absolutely no reverence for
like respective sizes because imagine
the scion he's like on the scion home
world with other scions he's like
freakishly tall he can't fit through any
of the cyan doors
he probably is going to live like like
10 years at that size he's he's got like
a gland problem like he's he's eating
like so much food he's like got all
these medical problems
in and out of the hospital because his
bones can't support all that meat way
like this guy is like this guy's like a
this guy's a problem like a case study
in like issues but but no he's just
bigger and he and he gets to be the boss
in a fight i just i i would think i went
on like an hour-long diatribe because i
was doing a grand master that happened
to be during that strike and so it took
us a long time to beat it and i was just
like talking about all the different
ways that this guy would would be a
serious problem in his entire
social circle in life
so i was like there's everything over
he's like 12 feet tall and we're all
down here like yeah he's like he's like
yeah it'd be it'd be like if cog if you
knew somebody who was 18 feet tall
yay and like and you know what i mean
like you just can you imagine all the
problems like there would be no beds to
fit them no clothes this poor guy would
we'd probably last like three years it's
an absolutely logistical nightmare
a day yeah it yeah
i can't remember is it the bus the scion
bus
yeah that sounds right yes
yes yeah yeah cargo yes absolutely i've
always loved the cable i just even from
d1 when people hated them i just thought
they were funny because i felt they they
had their own theme when you hear that
[Music]
i just think that
they were
on the theme don't they yeah
we just never got much that was just the
most memorable because it's so different
it's so different it's just so obvious
it's just brutish and i just love
everything about them it's violence and
it did uh killing and then you okay we
respect you and you killed our guy all
right cool
try to fix it
great is there a cabal raid am i
blanking well i mean yeah we just talked
about spiral stars yeah
yeah
but yeah that was like a few of them yes
i'm very curious to see if we do get
callous to ever come back at some point
as now possibly one of the disciples in
the darkness that'll be
be interesting to see like if this level
of storytelling telling they've got if
he comes back as somehow an off-season
shoot or you know a valve of the
disciple or anything like if that ever
actually transition happens the fact
that kyle's been built up this much to
see her going back and forth with her
dad
that would be some fun storytelling to
watch that would be really cool
yeah
i think uh like i really like one of my
favorite gm's is proving grounds
it's like
like she she does go on a little bit in
that don't she to be to be fair to her
after doing it like however 100 times
you're like
can you just can you just show up a
minute love you she doesn't go on it
she's just drones on and on and on but
yeah i think that was the start of this
cabal people being a bit more interested
in the command wanted and them telling
this story a bit more
uh
nightfall or that strike was was
released
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah the season of the
story but we're also that was the end of
the quest
so obviously this is probably our
shortest for all these like weekly
quests and things this is the shortest
one we have had
the basically actually wrapped
i know i complained last year all damn
year year long about not putting a bow
on a story and they finally put a bow on
that story and that thing is done now
they may do like an apple like they've
been listening to the show yeah i mean
yeah they they must totally shout out to
bungie you guys if you're out there we
love you um
but seriously it's like this is nice to
see one and it could have been even a
little longer it does it feel short but
it felt tight and it felt you know well
told and you know the different pieces
to it it didn't it's one of those you
know do you need the three-hour movie or
can you have the two-hour movie we got
the two-hour movie but we got the ending
which i appreciate so now if we do get
maybe an epilogue or a little preview
for whatever season happens in 17
that is totally fine and they can go
into what i had hoped for but the fact
that we actually got a season and tied
it up and it's
we know iron banner is going to change
in season 17. now we know it's going to
change a little bit more and why which
i'm very curious about
but
it's weird to see that the story we've
got the expansion story done
got the raid and now we've got the
season of the risen story and this was
week four
this is probably the fastest we have
gone through
basically any of an entire season's
beats for story lord narrative weekly
quests or anything ever
so i honestly kind of wanted to get your
takes do you guys think this went too
fast proper speed
are you worried about the next
10 or 11 weeks any of you guys whoever
wants to go first yeah i think this was
perfect and i think bungie is finally
realizing that they don't have to put
out content every week for people to
keep playing their game and even if
people stop playing their game they'll
always come back when there's new
content and i think that is a super
important lesson to learn when you're
making a game as a service because you
can never feed the beast to its
satisfaction at all times it's just an
unattainable goal
and more and more games as a service uh
you know custodians are realizing you
know what it's okay if there's dips it's
okay if if uh you know the week before
the witch queen comes out there's only
60 000 people playing it on steam
because then there's 800 numbers playing
it
yeah yeah still great but still it's uh
you know comparatively really low when
there was a million pre-orders for the
witch queen right uh that that's a very
uh small
number of players so um
yeah i i think that they're they're sort
of learning that i think that's super
important i mean nowadays there's lots
of games that follow that model sea of
thieves uh is sort of used to that
fluctuation they they have a lot of
people fall off and then they put
something out and lots of people play
and i think that that's okay i think
this is perfect to be honest because i'm
just getting
to the the point where i sort of feel
like i've done everything and i don't
want to do more psyops battlegrounds and
all that stuff and i'm kind of like all
right i've seen everything that's in the
witch queen i'm kind of starting to fall
off of it and and it all wrapped up i
don't have to worry about it and now i
can go and play elden ring and do other
stuff and then come back to it when
they're ready to tell me another story
and of course i'll come back because my
experience this time was so much fun and
i didn't have to wait too long for it
and all that stuff so i prefer this way
way way more like they can take a break
they can come back with more stuff it
also feels like
the this is more sustainable like i feel
like they can do a season where it's
just four or five weeks and then and
then take a little bit of a break and
and they can still tell really good
stories and make really good content but
i feel like trying to make three months
worth of content and then three months
of content immediately after that is
just not
sustainable and we kind of saw that with
all the delays so i'm i'm very uh happy
with how this worked and uh i hope that
they continue to to just tell their
story wrap it up and not not fear the
player base dropping because they they
will hopefully know that people are
going to come back to them so what about
you cog
where's this hit for you
it's been excellent it's been excellent
um
i'm gonna actually
weirdly disagree with travis even though
he made excellent
only from a selfish standpoint only
because
the narrative is so damn good
i'm addicted now and now i'm in the i
have ibotta's syndrome in a little bit
it's like well i don't have your
schedule because you you got the rap
this time like you were pissed off last
season because it's like yo don't leave
us with you know tune in next four
months for the next episode of this week
with sabbath doing in the crystal you
know like i get you so now it's just
like
man this is so good like i i'm like
literally was just tuning in to i guess
the reason why i was a little
sad
was that i felt like damn i feel like
it's so early in the season like i
thought i was gonna get at least like
two or three more weeks i'm being greedy
i know i'm being greedy this is the the
raid has been great the story with roke
after what you do you know the the
preservation you know what i'm saying as
you know getting the little points on
that i'm just curious though even though
every like i said travis is completely
on point with everything he said i'm
just curious
are they truly going to sit on
everything narrative
until this season is over because how
much time can i talk about
i don't know 11 weeks or something i'll
look over the calendar and we'll get to
that here in a minute we actually got
one it's not that long but i was like
but looking at the calendar it appears
we are not probably going to get too
much else with regards to the story from
what i can see on the calendar we're
going to get guardian games which is
always its own little thing but it's
iron banners it's trials freelance and
trials
capture and then master raids and raid
challenges but that's kind of we're
looking at the calendar now and i think
the story is kind of wrapped i mean the
quest even had 28 parts and it was like
seven per week and were we just tapped
it so yeah we are interesting kind of
done
yeah the last point i'm sorry no i was
gonna say a new red said there's a lore
page missing but i mean it's that's one
of those like minimal things where there
might be and that's where i think there
may be
an epilogue to lead into season 17. and
that if they have
this basically rap story crow does its
thing we stopped the invasion
of like trying to get the throne world
projection shout out to the moon
battlegrounds one of the coolest looking
ones of all yeah sure
but the fact that that is kind of
tightly wrapped there may be one more
experience we don't know about for the
towards the end but that's one of those
things they
they can save till later and just have a
surprise to be like hey this is going
into 17 as opposed to waiting for that
moment which i appreciate so yeah my
final point was just that you know
to travis's point where this could be a
positive thing is for the overall health
of the studio and the fact that okay
it's out and let's be honest
we we here at the kfi all the hardcore
right we are the guys that you know
we're helping people or being helped to
go through content we're going through
at a fast pace the normal human being
you know said who you know is really
working the nine to five really doesn't
have a lot of time may pop in for a few
hours here and there for a week they
will complete it at the pace of the
normal cicadas of the season they'll
they'll catch up so in that sense maybe
they have you know said to themselves
okay you know what why time gate
anything why hold it yeah right let them
get it and then hey if we want to pop in
a little extra mission by the midweek
part and then maybe towards the end set
up for epilogue moment we'll do that and
we're fine we know who we are they're
comfortable in and it would be a
refreshing change for them but i'm
curious what uh what my granddad got to
say on this whole thing with the story
being wrapped are you ready for 11 mo 11
weeks of sherpas go
yes
i think i agree i agree with uh with
travis about it
that i think that finally realized that
the you know there's different different
sets of player base there's a people
like us who will just play the game
anyway
and we'll have plenty to do because
we'll be doing our gm's our
master master er raids our challenges in
the raids so we've got enough to keep us
busy trials every week and iron banner
when it comes around we'll play the game
anyway but then if kate had sort of
catered to us in the way that
we've got the end of in our story quick
and we're it's not time gate we're not
got it sitting in our quest library on
uh come back next week it's on step 12
of 135
we actually know the ending of the story
uh
but like the the the the uh the casual
people as well can just come in play the
game know what's going on and then go
and play something else
which i'm pretty jealous of them type of
people who play other games like elden
ring and stuff that's mine i can only
play destiny yeah but uh yeah i think
they will do something but i i am a bit
like cog as well i'm i'm just being
greedy i feel like
a few more weeks
a few months just stretched out a little
bit more
yeah just crazy talking
to another tuesday bro i was so looking
forward to sign i played so much psyops
for law in a minute so that it's a
testament right granted like to how
good it's been yeah it's like man it's
like i know it's interesting yeah
i was sorry to interrupt you i was going
to say like it to your point cog like
they ended the story before you could
even buy all the upgrades to sap's
battlegrounds exactly yeah they're
they're really saying like hey if you
want to keep playing here's all the
reasons to you can grind high stat armor
and weapon rolls and all the stuff but
like they don't feel a need to just like
torture you with a story and make you
basically the fomo's gone right like
yeah like if i don't play for eight
weeks i know that all all granddad's
doing is the stuff that i probably don't
want to play anyway right like he's
doing like grandmaster nightfalls and
like he's grinding sops again and again
and again to get those upgrades and
doing all the stat stuff and it's like
cool if you want to build craft if you
want to unlock all those weapons for
weapon crafting like go crazy man like
that's totally there for you but uh you
don't feel like you have to and i kind
of like that yeah
or you'll miss like a vital part of the
story or something that's important i
just i think that's such a that's such
smart game design when it comes to games
of the surface it should be the standard
we didn't even know we didn't even fill
out that final tube as well did we in
the uh the thing because we had the hive
the hive guardians didn't mean them
tubes but it was one that was empty i i
think the one that was actually filled
i think that one got filled up with the
uh the wizard was like a wizard right
before right before the the
plug got pulled yeah
which i'd say yeah she was in the tube
for about like 30 minutes and then
crooked right right yeah didn't last
long so he did get filled
but no i mean i think you guys all
nailed it and then um shout out to jamie
in chat he just said he's like gotta say
which queen was crazy surpassed all my
expectations and i loved it but i feel
like i'm already back to the standard
destiny grind and i think this is
literally the perfect time for it to
hit the moment where you don't have to
log in every week and see the story and
then go through and be like oh i have
too much intel like it flirted with that
line of just enough times that they want
you to log in to see it where you're
like alright i can do about a month of
destiny but if i go
10 weeks like eight two months of this
then it's gonna feel like a little too
much for some people some of us crazy
people who do content or stream or
sherpa or whatever it is that we do uh
shout out to my dog she's making a
little cameo you guys can't see it but
yeah
um
but it is that like almost
perfect amount we got i got a story with
a bow which worked for me they could add
a little epilogue later which is also
good and then it's also for some people
when they're getting to that point of
feeling a little grindy you're good
like it it almost is that right amount
of four weeks
what's up travis
i was gonna say one more thing that i
and i think i can win cog over with this
even though he's addicted to the game
because what jamie said i actually think
is really important which is he said i
really like the content they provided
but now i'm back to the same old grind
and i'm not enjoying it anymore and i
think that if you spend less time
focused on feeling like you constantly
have to feed the beast with the story
content it allows you to focus on the
core grind of destiny and improve that
which has been in a really bad place for
a long time i mean that's why that's why
the witch queen got an eight right
because all the new content was great
but it's the old stuff that they didn't
fix that's that came back to haunt the
game and i feel like now they've got 11
weeks where presumably the narrative
team or whoever's building next season
is off doing that and now they can have
the team actually focus on improving the
core grind of destiny which is its
biggest existing problem crucible you
know being kind of a dumpster fire at
times the uh the activities that you're
supposed to do and being completely uh
grindy and not fun most of the time like
gambit and the strike playlist and all
this stuff that like at its core needs
fixing i feel like now they can focus on
and that that i feel like is another
benefit we're going to see so yeah it's
very very well possible and it don't
again we we have to see the uh long-term
ramifications of the sony move how that
plays in resource-wise and stuff like
that look i i know i'm being selfish and
gritty like i just know it it's a
testament to how good this thing is
every week i was coming getting a nice
good psyops meal i was i was very full i
was like oh man i'm on the edge of my
seat so it's just a little sad that's
like it really hit me with issa yeah now
that it's wrapped up and i'm like oh
yeah it is right but it was like that as
you said it's like they're telling it
well they they have us interested in
these characters they're actually
getting cool character development with
other races and alliances and moments
where saladin steps in and does this
like hits you in the fields and all of
these things are happening which is
really cool and but as you're saying
it's just like it's when it's to a point
where you want more they did it right
it's like hey you watch you correct
exactly that's like that's the first
you watch a season of tv and you're like
oh it's that 24 episodes yeah you had
some fillers in there maybe it's the
netflix was ten then they bumped it down
to eight and they're finding that amount
of a season
that leaves you wanting and this is one
of the things we've been preaching about
forever is like if you're at a point
that we are
um
basically
you
what's the blizzard thing that came up a
few years ago if you leave a game at
some point you'll leave whether it's
good or bad right if you leave the game
in a happy state you will be happy to
return when there's more if you leave a
game annoyed pissed off whatever grinded
to your like hate everything then you're
probably not going to come back and if
they if this is the walk they're finding
for more of the casual player wants to
see the story and dip and go play
horizon or tunic or elden ring or
have a nice death like my backlog is
always growing so the fact that i get
breaks now for variety and stuff oh it's
excellent yeah it's like but i love what
we've got
i love what we've got going on here
where cog is like the senior graduating
with like tears in his eyes where he's
like sad that there's not more and then
ibontis is looking at uh looking at
his college which is eldon ring with
like senioritis like he's not even
showing up for class anymore he's like
over this i got elden ring over there
i'm excited to get out of this place
it's great what it is is i think
every everybody is correct all of your
correct i think what it is is i think
this is the first time
bungie's trusting
themselves and the content
and understanding their game and and
that's what we're we're seeing the
maturity of the studio
and it's fun it's cool to see because
you made a good point but part you made
it was excellent which is you know it's
good when you've left the the base
wanting more
and then the hardcore can go grind out
do what they need to do mid max custom
and then to travis's point we will get
into the 12 where they like look we do
realize this grind with these resonance
weapons so maybe we got this time for 11
weeks to fine-tune this get your
feedback and all that other stuff but
yeah it's it it's it's it's cool to see
them grow up it's just weird for me you
know to see it in a way i'm like oh wow
it's it's really old okay
it's been a journey yeah from starting
this podcaster and curse of osiris to be
sitting here oh it's a different it's a
different game now which is really
really exciting but yes like iron banner
is going on this week we don't have to
touch on it too long um
if you guys have jumped in whether
you're playing pvp whether you played
trials or anything did has anybody
played much iron banner or trials this
past seven days
what's happening in these streets it's
real bad and
your granddad i i think you mentioned
something earlier in the show about this
so maybe i should let you talk a little
bit uh yes i've i've really enjoyed iron
banner
uh yeah yeah yeah i have with me yeah
avoid uh we've avoided uh child of the
old gods
child of the old gods yes i
yeah i love it but i i uh obviously
start the stream and get
a load of pvp gods to
uh
six stack with me so
it's probably a different experience for
me there's not many games we lose anyway
but then if i start start it up on my
own uh it'd probably be a different
matter
but whenever these uh these young
whippet snappers
uh
i don't get the bounties done very
quickly because they're all based on
kills
that's more your tenacity to stay at it
and be like hey i got one more kill this
match sweet no just kidding yeah yeah
yeah
uh and trials uh did our own trials we
went flawless on saturday morning shout
out to me friends espion infinity he
helped me every week
uh
so yeah but
yeah i'll be enjoying it but i have
heard a lot of people complaining about
yeah
crucible at the moment so
basically it's not in a good place
yeah basically the state is that void
3.0 is pretty imbalanced and it's just
like what they did with stasis it's just
exposed a bunch of exploits in the
sandbox and people are just taking
ultimate advantage of it right now the
invisibility with the hunters the
different the just the complete
imbalance between like warlocks and
hunters versus titans that have like no
place in crucible they have like no
place in crucible right now because none
of their supers are are well suited for
for trials none of them like you put a
bubble down that doesn't help you you
can put up a shield that gives everybody
more damage behind you doesn't help you
and then the roaming super with the
shield is also just terrible it it
there's really no place for for for it
but you kind of have to play as a void
titan because of the overshield yeah i
was going to say the void titan
overshield
putting up a putting up a barricade and
not immediately getting it over shield
is now like an offense i'm like
i'm like what i'm like where's my
overshield i put up my belly barricade
you know what i mean like i'm like upset
by it and so yeah it's uh it uh it you
have to play as it but like the supers
and just the exploits it's
i didn't play trials because i played a
little bit of iron banner and i was like
okay i'm starting to see the exploits
i'm gonna give them a couple weeks to
patch this and then i'll jump into trial
so that's my plan is like i'm just gonna
kind of wait for the for the patches to
come through i'm sure they'll be coming
in this weekend next week
it just needs to happen they built they
they clearly build their their ability
sandbox around pve like that's just very
clear in the design and so you kind of
have to wait for it to get cleaned up
and actually designed for a pvp
environment and so after playing tr
after playing a chris
iron banner for a little while this week
i was like all right i'm going to let
you guys uh clean this up and then i'll
be back for some problems let me ask you
let me ask you this i got it is it as uh
insufferable as
this is first no no no no no it's not as
bad as like shadow dive no no no no no
no no
what is the pain point y'all like is it
invisible
literally i mean you go all three
hunters invisible
warlocks with you know you've got child
of the old gods you've got you know
you've got your ability you always have
a rift that you can literally walk back
and forth and heal them stop hate stop
hating don't worry i i don't like your
reflection watch your tone i mean
that's been there forever you can you
literally be like hold on just stand
here and always heal
forever and now you got a child of the
old gods that goes to chase people down
or hiding around the corner now you're
like suppressed it's like yeah so i mean
you've got that option
your grenades can get bigger you can
always have devour like there are things
but i mean titans as well you can
take a shield which as travis said
solar and solar and arc feel useless
because when you put that shield up and
you're like cool i got that overshield
when you put a shield up you're like
wait i didn't get my overshield it feels
like that that shield needs to be doing
something else
it feels like solar needs to do
something feels like arc needs to do
something cause solar cause void does
something with that shield now if you
want it to and most people are gonna
lean into that
uh and yeah new reds over there like
devour stronger than overshield so it's
like you've got a lot of options in each
of these
because it's interesting but as you as i
forget who said it they lean into this
for pve and this is where i don't want
them to touch pve because void is a lot
of fun
yeah we gotta be careful yeah
they're they're leaning into wells now
which is fine you know i'm learning in
to build into wells now which is fine
volatile rounds and those things and you
got the mods and aspects that go for it
but if they neuter pve just to make pvp
a little more balanced they need to
split that down the middle and make sure
they keep them separate because pve is
fun then you can go travel to people
lately which they have yeah
yeah but i just want to make sure they
don't
yeah well yeah and then of course they
take the one solar helm for titans and
before everything launches nerf that in
the ground the new one this season is
toast
you sound like you're going through it
as a titan what could we do to help what
could we have let's see
we went through it with stasis which was
absolute [ __ ]
for titans for an entire year
and then for
now granted
titan's fun i like my overshield like
it's fun bubbles is super viable yeah
and raid that's invaluable but it's just
like
in pv now i will say in pvp i don't
think it's as bad because my overshield
i can guarantee it's probably as
frustrating as but i will also say if
there's an invisible hunters and i'm
like where's
invisible the thing that you can shoot
an invisible hunter and they don't
become uninvisible
oh wow they hold it
oh and then they can keep it forever you
can basically be invisible nearly in
infinitely the way that is done their
builds for that so
really ninjas yeah but i was like but my
overshield does make it to where it's
like hey i'm just gonna pop this shield
like facing a doorway so anywhere in
front of this doorway i'm constantly
regenerating the overshield i'm like i
can be annoying too i get that so it's
not as bad as like behemoth i get that
okay yeah i'm not saying it's not yeah
but remember y'all the one-eyed mass
days
yeah remember
them okay
handheld supernova don't forget those
days
oh no you were you can kiss my hind
quarters
yeah there's always there's always been
imbalances yeah and just to be clear i'm
not saying like oh titan's got a bad rep
i'm just saying
all of the powers that were given
overshield healing devour invisibility
none of them feel like they were
designed for crucible and they they
almost certainly weren't right and so
when you bring those into an ultra
competitive sandbox like trials it isn't
super interesting or fun to see all of
these different overpowered not pvp
design mechanics being being exploited
to play the game in really weird ways
and so i'm not saying oh boohoo titans
i'm saying i don't know i'm just being
the pvp sandbox feels bad no matter what
clash you're playing on it feels bad and
they need to tune it before i'm gonna
play that's all it's like i'm just gonna
stay out of there and let them figure it
out so no don't that's it that's it i
mean this is the problem of pvp and
destiny is that it we're always the
stepchild where they think about us
after everything else is oh yeah that's
all you're done and squared away and so
yeah i'm just gonna wait that's it i'm
gonna wait for him to fix it and they'll
come back and i'm sure it'll be fine
the thing is no i'm sorry
the thing is is that like when when they
do it the solar when solar gets that
treatment that's gonna be the same
that's gonna be overpowered
and then when they do act the same
that'll be overpowered so i hope they
don't neutral all too much because like
stasis is
a bit
you know
a bit lackluster now isn't it because
they've took everything out of it near
enough i mean it's they nerfed it for an
entire year
but
it took him long enough uh
it's
i don't know if they would have been
better to release it all at once you
know all the light subclasses instead of
doing it season by season like they are
going to do yeah uh
because if if if
the way that void is now if they then
nutrition it's just a bit
a bit crap
it's i think it's gonna
gonna be a shame if you would have done
them all at once
then they could balance a bit better
because they're gonna have to do the
same job again and again and that's
probably why they've done it like that
because if he would have
done all three at once
and things in there yeah yeah it would
have absolutely pulled the game that
sandbox would yeah i was like that's
honestly the reason they're doing that
has to just be for
development
as much polish as they can do before it
gets sent out the door knowing it's
still probably going to be broken and
then taking that season to tweak while
the other half of the dev team is
building the next one same cycle is
going to continue because yeah you're
going to get void 3.0 you're going to
have throwing hammers that are all of a
sudden busted in sunspots and weird
stuff going on you're going to have
60 000 little ark souls flying
everywhere i mean stuff's going to be
chaos when some of this stuff launches
and we know it it's going to be fun it's
going to be crazy it's going to be great
and it's just kind of what we expect and
this is why
season 17 is gonna be maybe solar and
then season 18 is
arc and then season 19 before we get to
lightfall is gonna be let's see if we
can
get some of this stuff in check on this
final season of no new subclasses before
maybe we get like a poison subclass or
if we get anything else coming in the
future which
throw a wrench into everything again so
it does keep them busy for sure but it
is weird when you go hey i got a void
shield and that thing gives me an
overshield now or if i do a shoulder
charge i get an overshield and then you
go into another subclass and you're like
back to void it just it it doesn't feel
that great so it is it is one of those
where i'm with you it's like the six
months of waiting for whatever that last
subclass is it's gonna be a long wait
yeah i agree my point final point which
is i actually agree with uh grand then i
think it's
overpowered by design yeah i think they
they literally use it as a marketing
tool yeah look how cool this new thing
that we made guys look at all this stuff
and to travis's boy none of this is
where pvp is
this is hey hey man you saw that trailer
don't you want to use childhood
don't you want to use volatile rounds
and blow stuff you could be a living
well-making machine look at this build
and you sell it you put those trailers
and i ain't gonna lie e i finally got
the um you i'm very happy i will not
curse out law sectors no more on my
third attempt i got the warlock boots i
was very happy
yeah all day oh they're excellent oh
yeah excellent but um yeah it when i got
them i'm like okay this build is broken
like this is just
nonsense what i'm doing right now like i
get devour by putting a rift down and
overload on any gun
by just putting a rift down yeah that i
was like oh this is this is i'm gonna
have way too much fun
yeah but yeah it's marketing it's
walking and then they reel it in because
i believe the guys that they had on was
it um
yeah i think they brought it down four
times after lunch or something they knew
it was yeah yeah they did
so it's like i'll be kind of curious how
much of this here's a cool thing and
let's bring in balance because we're
going to do a yoyo of that it seems like
all year and the lightful is going to be
the big yoyo again
i feel like we've just accepted this but
the thing is it doesn't have to be this
way they could build the they could
build the new abilities
3.0 with a pve and a pvp build in mind
but i feel like they've always
pvp has always been an afterthought
where they're like well let's build it
for the pve experience and then we'll
fix it in post when it comes to pvp i
feel like that is not a great philosophy
like the the fact that we just have to
deal with the chaos in uh in the pvp
community so they need to
like like e has been saying like
everybody's been saying forever they
need to even more further separate kind
of the damage outputs and the some of
the abilities and the way they work and
just make it make it a little bit better
at launch because i don't think it feels
good it was funny when they did it
once you know for laser tag weekend
because yeah it was in such a bad spot
at that point i still feel like that was
an intentional marketing ploy they were
just like let's make this uh laser tag
just insane to get
community jazz but i feel like it's kind
of lost a little bit of its
uh
novelty since the days of stasis when it
was like broken
and then now it's like it just doesn't
feel good they need they need to fix the
way that uh the way that they're
deploying these new abilities uh and not
maybe not break pvp or at least be
quicker to fix it it just yeah there's
yeah
that's what i'm that's my biggest hope
for the sony acquisition the resources
because i actually honestly just think
it's a business decision they literally
whatever the live team can't handle in
conjunction with you know
them really their focus is still this is
a pve game they they to me they're very
data driven and analytic driven
and yeah they they they know where their
base is playing so hopefully
this could i'm hoping that that influx
besides movies
i think you're going to keep waiting on
the endpoint
i think i think there's going to be a
brain drain at bungie because sony wants
to make 10 other games as a service game
and i think they're gonna they're going
to be
using a lot of the bungie staffing to do
that i think it's going to be the exact
opposite of what you guys are saying but
i'll i'll be happy if i'm wrong yeah
yeah be interested in the money to see
what happens moving forward with this
acquisition it's like final other thing
i'll say for what's going on before we
get to twab uh good luck in gambit
dodging those ariana valve shots and
best of luck everybody
ariana grande one shot body shot you
yeah it's getting pve damage values
for a pvp type interaction so you can
one shot body somebody with and there
are a few other guns that are broken too
it's not the only one but ariana is his
one-shot body so it's like damn it
it's really interesting
season of ariana we gonna get a new
emblem with a hole going through our
heads and eres's picture
through the leg but the eyes will be
dead so it's like a leg
it's like a shoelace tackle but the
shoelace shot like i shot him in the toe
ted
so
anyway
yeah go look up a gamut clip or
something it's it's kind of crazy so
wow
i enjoyed gambit this week i'd really
enjoyed it yeah
i i wasn't i wasn't using ariana's but
one of my fights he was and uh
yeah we just made sure we had our our
damage down you know so we don't go so
the boss didn't go through all through
all three phases
and we were just like wiping seems out
he was great
it sounds like you've been you've been
working on his team you've been
wondering
yeah but i was getting killed off it as
well so it's fair game isn't it yeah
like everybody technically can at this
point
well we also got this thing called the
twab today and got a little interesting
stuff in it for a change which is not i
would say for a change we've had so much
going on in game we haven't needed much
in the 12 but we did get some
interesting we got our first calendar
they let the season kind of settle so
you got our first calendar so this week
is iron banner the new uh psyops
battlegrounds next week legend psyops
battlegrounds so i'm guessing that's
going to be about 1550 for a level if
that holds true to like the missions
we've got what do you guys see coming
from legend that's different than it is
now
it better be a good reward
better chance at deep sight weapons more
of that risen umbral energy there's not
a whole lot that i'm gonna need to go
farm legend for so i'm not entirely sure
what that's gonna be
it could be uh double perks on the
weapons can it select yeah
yeah yeah no one buys you yup yup maybe
maybe high stack armor yeah
good call i will definitely say at the
war table if you do pick up like if you
focus into the ward table armor solid
stats so far i've done it a few times
and each one's 63 to 66 like they're all
pretty spiky distribution so if you are
in need of armor and don't already have
like 12 sets then if you're new it's not
a bad place to spend it the focusing for
a weapon man that crap is expensive
though i did a video it's nine for a
weapon
and it is very pricey so it's like
honestly if you have a lot of umbrella
engrams you got like nine just dump them
into just the gear one that's like one
and i've honestly you can either get one
weapon for nine or you can get nine
pieces of gear if you have enough umbral
engrams and i've gotten like multiple
red outlines from doing that so
depending on your umbrella in gram to
reasonable energy ratio
there are better ways to spend that but
anyway here's here's my proposal for
legend psyop battlegrounds you guys
ready yes i'm right right so you get in
legends that battlegrounds you get to
replay through all four weeks of the
psyop battleground story but if you play
through the legend version and the final
week when you get to the part where
crook kills everybody you get to slap
him and go no stop it don't do that
that would be worth the payoff
yeah hit a to slap down don't do that
stop it and then and then it changes the
story yeah are you getting snazzy little
snazzy little feather suit
that'd be good
i am not sure you remember
it yeah yeah
girl got a fire
he's like
the disciple challenges so it's like if
you've been running the raid a few
consistent times we've got our run down
pretty packed i mean it's like hour 75
minutes depending on it's like it's
pretty smooth with our group if you got
a decent at this point especially if you
have roles in the um x what is it
exhibition section
uh if you have your roles in that one
pretty well defined it's pretty smooth
all the way through so challenges will
be interesting so it'll probably start
on totems first do it in a different way
and then you've got
just the different ways to do certain
things so i'll be kind of curious what
they
what the challenges are do you guys have
any speculation of how they're going to
change up the encounters he's got totems
caretaker exhibition and then of course
rulk
do you guys have any thoughts of how
they would do challenges like what
specific thing are you gonna need to do
cause what was one of the ones in vlog
where you can't kill
uh one of the big champions or the guys
for the totems until they're actually
dunking on it like yeah yeah so i know
there are certain things
yeah one of their favorite the go-to's
is like you can't do anything more than
once so i could see like oh i know
i could see like a different person has
to go into the hall to get the emblem
and the the caretaker encounter every
time or
uh you know some somebody
only one person can can shoot each of
the totems every time or something like
that it'll be like weird where it's like
everybody's rotating positions and
people are going to be like no but i've
only ever staggered the ogre this is the
worst and i'll be like yeah well
learn to do everything isn't that one of
the triumphs already though yeah i think
there's some traps in there
each a few friends have done the
triumphs but because i've been helping
people i've not really uh
looked at them because i know the first
one is uh you've got a
way to kill the uh yellow bars yeah
until they're actually attacking the
obelisk
shoot the obelisk
yeah
so you can forget having any chain
reaction uh oh galahar no no oh no i
don't like i don't i don't like any
challenges that are like you have for
this challenge you have to play destiny
poorly like yeah yeah yeah
not kill the ads
come on man
it's like those are not fun challenges
you're like hey i want to be i'm really
good at clearing efficiency built into
void hold
wait
but they're walking closer hold on
what about this thing we're trying to
defend you got to let him shoot at first
i'm sorry what yeah yeah like what that
it's so the challenges do seem
counterintuitive like vlog's another
example of that as well
uh what was it you had to
i was on gatekeeper the gatekeeper
challenge i
think i tried to help fallout do that
like one time and it was the only one we
didn't end up doing because you had to
kill them only with the shield or
something like there's certain weird
things
and it's like those don't yeah it's
mechanics heavy to a point where it's
not fun
yeah so then on that shield one it used
to give you shield energy if you picked
up arbs and then last season
the uh
they took it so arbs didn't didn't give
you uh the shield energy
which made it even worse because i was
still i was helping people with the
master challenges for the uh
last season and it was a lot harder last
season to do it because
there was a cheese but
but still like that's that's one of
those things when you're like just
because you balanced the game this
triumph that's sitting in the game now
became even more of a pain in my butt
like yeah exactly that doesn't seem
necessary so we'll see what the
challenges are
uh i was like i'm trying to think about
totems as you said if that's the
challenge that's the triumph if it's the
same one that's on there then
yeah you'll get to wait it's just like
master difficulty is gonna be a little
more annoying when he gets around to
trying to do a challenge on master or
anything but my my only concern is
i i believe they confirm that
the uh the watch call is going to have a
the massive difference we end up to the
math difficulty
when we get to the massive difficulty
yeah we'll get to it i got some thoughts
so yeah we'll see what those are those
will kind of go on a weekly basis for a
little while since you've got four
encounters basically four challenges so
we'll see what those are trials labs
zone capsule will be on the first
i don't hate zone capture i'll be
completely honest as a random solo
player
um just because
for one that made it tour it's always a
neutral location so it's like a b or c
but it's dead center and it makes you
use different part of the maps
but to me it would also help the randoms
because i always tend to go by myself
and whether you're against a three stack
i tend to get stomped most people do if
you're against the three-stop and you're
solo but if there's like six random
people in there everybody tends to head
in the general direction
and kind of works together a little
better than hey i'm gonna be the crazy
guy and go flank and die in a corner and
be useless so the zone capture does
actually tend to guide the idiots in the
right direction sometimes which i
appreciate
um april 5th is the day for granddad
grandmaster nightfalls open up so you'll
be uh cranking on those i know
get your light level up i'm sure it's
gonna be
what's it gonna be 1585 i'm guessing
with
artifact and i don't know
i still wish they would do grand masters
contest because all the grand master is
you have to get up to a certain level
but you can't be above it
yeah still yeah yeah i still wish that
was kind of i think it'll be uh if it's
like previous seasons which it probably
will be will it be 1575 i think maybe
15.75 yeah 15.75 probably 85. already
i'm sounding straight so i'd have to
worry about what happened yeah it was
like
a premium experience yeah if you get
your pinnacle grind done over the next
few weeks and then you know you got your
artifact up to about 15 16 you'll be
fine i think it's not gonna be hard to
get there april 8th mine trials lab
freelance is here i just appreciate that
because i don't face a three stack ever
it's just six random people sometimes
you're gonna win sometimes you're gonna
lose sometime the gods are on your team
sometimes they're on theirs but i do
tend to like i played trousers last
weekend and i got my seven wins i didn't
go flawless but i got my seven wins got
my 50 rounds got some reputation
and now that i got my seven wins i can
use the reputation card every time so
every match i play is getting me more
reputations and engrams for the rest of
the season and being as the alacrity
perk will give you
solo benefits yeah that's going to be
good for lost sector solo anything you
do so for me it's like yeah i'm going to
need to go get some of those
uh then we got iron banner on the 12th
so no trials valve the disciple master
raid on the 19th so cog you had thoughts
here what is up yeah this one i was uh
brought to my attention i didn't realize
so it looks like adept weapons are
coming up with this
but they're not
craftable from what i've heard so yeah
yeah from what i heard so the rumor is
that there's an aircraft so my question
is gonna be
if they're not craftable which we're
going to assume they're going to have a
debt perks i mean mods or whatever what
have you like
what will the advantage like the
advantage should have to be substantial
because
once it won't be able to
ride because if because look this is how
i'm looking at it right insidious is my
favorite weapon right now out of all
that like that i love that pulse like it
is the dad pulse it's e's favorite gun i
try to tease him as much as i can
because i'm oh
you got it and you're like oh this
thing's great i finally got one i
finally got one this week so i got it
uh rapid hit vorpal was my first one so
rapid
works
rapid hit on a pulse you get like the
stack start really fast so that works
but yeah i loved her you're like oh
that's a great gun i'm like i know yeah
the pulse rifle feels fantastic and i
finally got one back can't wait when our
3.0 drops and they do something with
that because it's going to be crazy with
that and i have dragonfly on it and it's
just it's just ignorant i love it so uh
but by what i'm saying is the goal for
me is keep keep raining
craft i want to get a potential
dragonfly rampage which is a rare combo
that can happen on that pulse
so i'm saying to myself okay if i get
that and i grind right and i have enough
residency you do enough raids
what is going to pull me off
if it's not craftable like what adept
mods could they do to make it really
worth
the while to not craft the basic version
of it that's my question to you guys
i don't think they're gonna surprise i
don't
as many the way the perks are set up in
the raid right now
as they already have some very cool and
unique perks in val the disciple as it
is
um there's some unique ones in there
then you've got the origin trait
i mean all the time lost ladies open up
like a depth so you had your adept big
ones which some people can find benefit
for that to have a little more
flexibility for the other slot
and then it was well like a baby stat
boost and now the masterwork is even
less needed they don't even say the
masterwork's worthwhile just in case you
do want the stats
i don't know what they're gonna do for
these i would love to be surprised but
my expectations are so low that master
is gonna be worthwhile being as we do
have crafting unless every time every
master drop is red outline
then if you ran that for you know a few
weeks then you could like burn through
your crafting a little bit more to get
people in and used to it that would
eventually come to an end once you got
your crafting builds
that
i don't honestly know like to me i can't
picture them
not doing so with if it's not game
breaking i don't think it's going to be
worth it to do it on master
i still wish they brought contests back
but that's a different discussion we've
already had
trouble granted what you guys think i
was going to say granddaddy what do you
think about master are you excited do
you like not like where you at i i just
opened up destiny then because uh
when cogs said about rampage dragonfly
insidious i thought
oh yeah sure i'm sure i've got one of
them so i just opened up destiny to look
good
it's just
it's so good so i've not even shot that
weapon i've got oh
[Music]
uh eight of them i've not i've not even
shot it
to my to my shame so i will definitely
use that yeah pull that up on fire once
in a while it feels pretty yeah yeah
i will give you guys this a a big
vow is moving up my rankings and for a
different reason other than what you
guys have said all right
i am a very i'm a big proponent of the
rewards awards
and i have to say
i haven't gotten the the exotics so i
can't speak on that i've seen video
shout out to that or and shout out dj
orals who got the damn thing with us
travis that night i was a cool guy get
it he made a video fallout probably
borrowed it yeah i've seen people have
it but i haven't touched it yet i will
say
almost
all of these weapons are impressive the
kinetic stasis um fusion yeah
amazing game changer for that slot
because now you can go stay at this
energy primary
well i can have stasis built you could
do a chill clip i got a chill clip roll
with a perpetual motion i'm just
destroying stuff with that i love it in
city with your city it's literally in my
opinion the best legendary right now in
my opinion what am i i'm not arguing the
wave frame the wave frame the one that
yeah
the only problem is that it's uh is
volatile rounds it's it's not fun
to play with it you need that you can't
play with it yeah yeah
but that i mean i haven't i don't have a
good roll on the linear yet but you know
i got a focus fury fourth time's the
charm
yeah yeah that's so if you can hit half
the crits and then you get more shots
back in that magazine now you're getting
that bonus damage for
a lot more no that's
it i was taking that through practicing
uh i was practicing what was i
practicing
uh oh i was just like soloing some of
the missions it hits it hits well
yeah and and submission if i'm a guy
that never got a good multi mac in the
kinetic spot for um
submission
i just don't have a good role no not
yeah that's not submission's good yeah
it feels good yeah yeah
and combine that
with the most underrated perk in the the
um intrinsic origin trade with this just
get a couple of hits reload get energy
back like it's like a baby
yeah that's a little bit it's a little
bit but depending if you get more kills
or more
you get a bigger chunk back these raid
weapons are really good the only thing
that may hold it back is is collective
the pulse is very
very specific you have to run a void
build you have to run suppression
weekend and all this stuff i'm hearing
yeah nothing exotic is tricky yeah it's
tricky it's very yeah it's very
particular but as a whole
this is up there i i have to give this
this file disciple weapons the legendary
is really worth it very good yeah and
especially the design as well oh i love
the best love
yeah yeah yeah like we've been asking
for a long time with to have uh weapons
and armor that
that are uh
as if they're taken from the range you
know elements from the design of the
raid so what they've done i think like
some of the armor does look ridiculous
but i think it should look ridiculous
yes
it is it is a little bit over the good
job
yeah
but uh about the adapts versions
like you said they're gonna have to make
it and i don't think they are gonna do
right he will just be they'll be a
little step see one each column won't
say something like that plus two
stability yeah that's what i was like i
would run that normal raid i would i i
would work on sherping more people in
that normal aid because i find it fun
it's a cool experience new rad said he's
like i don't think we've had a raid this
straightforward that's also so engaging
nice like nicely stated because it's
it's cool it's interesting the bosses
you see then you get a run and the cool
mechanics and new boss
and it's also not crazy long and it's
also
and it's well done but like master just
seems
i would rather go die a hundred times in
elden ring
happily
to like learn a boss fight that i'm
learning skill on than deal with master
because my issue with master
uh and i wish [ __ ] i wish grandmasters
obviously like come down to 1550 and b
contest there
so you don't have like you don't have to
spend time just playing just a level to
make yourself closer to the level of the
activity and that is just a time thing
and that's the only thing that's why
contests like contest was a tight tight
window when we finally got exhibition
and we nailed it i was like that felt
good but we were running so smooth and
we got it all and rock we were like
really close and yeah we never got it
but if contest was still there
eventually the next week we could have
worked on it we could have that contest
and get contest level rewards
yeah
i just yeah the the master
yeah i will do legend on most things but
master on most things i just don't
generally enjoy
and that's just me being like
i would i would rather do other things
than just be a time thing like that you
kind of shared it yeah i was like master
vox obscura i'm close and it's like i do
want to practice because that's like
i'll work on a video for that one but
that's the only one but it's like the
raid is very enjoyable and it does take
you know coordination but it just seems
unnecessary to be hey let me get you up
to 1580. well how do you get there well
gear stops here so then you if you get
20 more on your artifact after doing the
pinnacle grind which is just a time
investment and in theory you could over
level it you could be 20 plus 25 plus 30
and then it's probably going to feel a
little better but what is the time to
get plus 25 or 30 on your artifact now
in a short season not a six month season
i've never been that high on my season
pass so sorry for my rant anyway no no
good point
i think it's absolutely just uh an
opportunity missed by them not to
capitalize on contests
but for even adding that over 24 hours
was
was
was good wasn't it but it wasn't enough
obviously but
you just have it as a selectable yep
that's all you've got to do people can
have people can have that that that
choice
it's uh
you don't i i still think this should be
obviously a 24-hour
emblem a day one emblem
but this should be a different emblem
kind of
contest it's season long good point i
absolutely agree with that one yeah yeah
we were talking about different ideas of
you know if it was you know contest yeah
turn the toggle on at 24 hours so then
you can keep going and if you want to do
the 24 and you want to be the crazy
person honestly i thought the 48 for the
health of all the players was still good
yeah that was actually a nice piece but
i get like i get the 24 hour race for
the crazy dedicated the health of the
players would be the argument for the 48
but either way contest should be a
toggle
like a day after that raid is out it
should always be there because it's such
a it's a really cool experience and you
said if there's a a different emblem it
just lets one of the artists be like hey
here's another cool emblem yeah yeah
yeah it makes it it's difficult it's
challenging
but for
you know for for whatever reason some of
us you know
aren't cut out for
having
been up for 48 hours or whatever you
know what i mean
and some of us
take a few
it takes a bit to get into something and
to learn something do you know what i
mean so we need that extra time but we
know we could nail it you could easily
nail it if you had more time but
i do still think that you should have
that 24 hours for the for the people who
want to invest for that first 24 hours
uh
yeah
cool so yeah sorry i had a little lag
spike there chad if you guys do have any
viewing issues it should be back every
so often my internet just like drops for
like two seconds and we're good again so
that's all that was trap trap your
thoughts on it
uh yeah you guys covered a lot i was
trying not to interrupt anybody uh very
good
for the adept weapons i i personally i
think adept weapons have never been
worth it um i've never really grinded
for them this is somebody who has pretty
much all the adept like trials weapons
and a couple of the grandmaster ones but
um i don't think the adept weapons have
ever been worth it so i think that that
doesn't really change much people are
still going to grind for their god rolls
more than their
you know adept roles i i think
and then grand master nightfall to me
and master raid both feel
like not very fun activities because
they just sort of artificially inflate
the difficulty by making you feel way
weaker to the enemies which
you know doesn't make a whole lot of
sense considering it's an endgame
activity and then to ease point having
to grind to the max
rank just so that you can feel
underpowered in that activity is insane
to me it doesn't make any sense it's
like oh yeah grind to the most powerful
so that you can feel like you're like a
level one character just getting
destroyed uh you know by a scion single
sound just meleeing you to death oh yeah
one shot so i've never really felt like
those um those activities were super
super fun or enticing and uh and
definitely not rewarding enough to be
worth all the the juice is not worth the
squeeze on those things absolutely not
yeah for sure so
um i don't think this really changes a
lot it'll be there for the super
hardcore for the people who really are
masochists or just really dedicated and
want to challenge themselves and i think
that's fine like yeah it should
definitely be there for that i i think
it's
a good thing that bungie is not gating
anything important behind those
activities because i feel like that
would really piss a lot of people off
because it's not a particularly fun
experience so
i think it's fine as it exists it gives
gives them something but not too much
and it's definitely not for everyone i
mean the raid already isn't for everyone
so i yeah i'd be willing to bet if if
only what three percent of the community
does raids i bet you it's like zero
point zero zero zero zero one percent
that does master raids like that's crazy
that's a crazy that's going to be a
short list for sure and yeah it was like
we were a chat sitting there talking
about it too it's like
the hive in the campaign
so much cooler than champions and all
the higher difficulties do is just shove
more champions in in a lot of places
like the fact that we have hive
guardians cool experiences got to deal
with them a different way gotta actually
move in close the gap those are cool
experiences yeah crushing the ghosts
here's 12 under unstoppable champions
instead of six and you're like i don't
boy it's
it and then it for and then it forces
your loadouts to and then yeah
yeah we've talked about all this stuff
before but it's just the limitations of
all of that stuff gets to be a little
frustrating but one thing before we get
too long uh granddad you still good on
time
yeah okay cool okay um i know
no it's a little later across the world
for you but thought i'd still check and
see because i didn't want to touch one
oh
i was just going to say that ghost
crushing yeah the one part that doesn't
really make sense is that if you play as
a warlock or hunter character they also
just crush it in their hand and i feel
like they should the animation should be
different like if you're a warlock you
should like grab it and like try to
crush it and they're like yeah and then
you like hold it out to your friend and
then he comes back
i feel like yeah
well i actually liked what you just said
but i wasn't going to be quite as
disrespectful as you were going to be
no i thought the warlocks could like
take it and just like energetically like
like kind of be like an energetic crush
and then the hunter theoretically would
hold it and stab it with its knife yeah
yeah
you don't have to be good as
disrespectful but that's totally fine
i think you know that you know in lieu
of spending all that money on animations
maybe they could just hand it too tight
i was just thinking as well about that
master question that it's like for for
master vog you want like adept
palindrome so like every man and his dog
i remember we we
me and me mates like helped so many
people like
through uh
through master templar just to get the
depth challenge of pvp
never take it free
sorry favorite yeah
yeah i remember taking people through
who were like 100 200 like levels wow
under
wow
templar which is like baking
and uh they stand in a well or they
they'd have divinity i think we saw the
lowest we took through
if i if i remember rightly
it was something like twelve twelve
hundred wow
150
150 levels in the under the season thing
but
uh
yeah that was a reason for that i wanted
but i just can't see what they're going
to do for this one
it depends what caretakers holding and
supposing
what weapons behind there but you never
know there might be some crazy reason
why pvp has one one of the guns
as adapts yeah yeah because like what do
you expect some intrinsic icarus grip is
something i don't know
yeah vlog master was
um
obviously the adept kind of socket and a
little bit of the stats but it was more
like it was the curated role was the
option basically like if you got the
time lost you got the curated which had
kind of the god roll on the bottom and
maybe a couple random ones on the top
that was the general idea
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because if you got the if you got
opening shot with the uh
with the explosive payload that was
basically the god roll on it for pvp
but yeah for these weapons like you say
with the crafting
i don't know
yeah i want to think about that i was
thinking i doubt they do this but what i
did i i did like my first like was it
i'm asked tonight for like was it what's
the the highest the highest level
nightfall just right now yeah
grandmaster
yeah master i think and i got a hot head
that had i saw your tweet yeah yeah and
i'm like okay two origin trait uh perks
you had the vanguard one and then they
had this one stunning recovery that's on
normal nightfalls you can get the same
thing though
strikes and nightfall origins they do
both
but basically i say that to say this
that like what if i doubt it but what if
they give an additional
origin trait
with um what you call it the master
disciple yeah
maybe that could be an interesting one a
brand
that means all that time last season we
spent
grinding grinding the hot heads we need
yeah that's that soft sun setting that
happens everything says
yeah yeah okay uh anything else on the
everything else on the calendar is
basically iron banner trials labs
freelance they said they're gonna pepper
in some gambit labs that'll be
entertaining when it happens
uh and then guardian games may 3rd
through 24th do you want to spend any
time talking about guardian games
no
and i have a proposal for for gambit
labs is they should try turning it off
for a week to see how that experiment
works
that'd be a fun little lab
no gambit again and i don't give it and
on that bombshell for those who watch
top gear um
crafting
so i'm gonna go through this in a couple
points
i recorded my little video on this one
but i want to kind of get your guys
takes
so the biggest things about crafting are
obviously people have been doing
crafting for a little while there has
been some feedback we have vented it for
a few weeks in here
um
granted if you have any amazing feedback
pieces let us know but i'm sure yours
have been something similar
uh they said one feedback piece in
particular deals with the crafting
element caps screaming everybody screams
this loud from the rafters as some
players may have been maxing out their
elements frequently starting next
tuesday with hotfix 4.04 will be
increasing element caps these are the
legendary elements from 250 to 1000
okay
that doesn't seem so bad
don't worry i'm about to get real angry
and then neutral elements the cap will
move from 8 500 to 10 000.
so we go from 250 to a thousand you go
4x for capacity and then you go 8 500 to
10 000. it's i don't even think that's
1.2
it is the smallest little bump in
neutral and that's the one you can spend
4 000 on one weapon
the max you can spend on one weapon is
140.
why is that not like 50 000 come on
and then that takes me into the next
point next season and this is gonna get
rid of oh yeah
thank god i i i have no idea how all
these different currencies made it into
the game because it was a bad idea the
second we learned about it and bungie
immediately agreed how did this get into
the game it's so crazy to me so next
season they are removing ruinous a droid
mutable energetic and drowned which is
from the raids only neutral element will
will remain which makes the cap even
worse unless they change the costs
now they get rid of glimmer now get rid
of glimmer bungee get rid of it
all right
artifact power level get rid of
everything yeah get rid of that yeah
just anyway make it make it call of duty
i don't want any inventory
make it so you can stack as many
ascendant shards
you don't have to master work [ __ ]
exotics yes so you can keep them in
evolve yeah here's the thing here's the
thing
you don't get it you don't get it those
golf balls they're so shiny they just
take up all that extra memory space
and that it's really a technical
limitation glitter effects to change the
database number from 10
to 99 it's the same digits
yeah i'm not even a coder but i have
done some coding in my life it's it's in
so intentional it pisses me off anyway i
do want to cover this a little bit 150
over 150 ascending shards i had lost
last season
see that's wrong the amount of work you
put in and that's the thing is like they
do the limitation which is
it annoys the people who are kind of in
the middle level who play some grand
masters may save up a little and then
lose it you do so many grand masters
you're swimming in them you don't yeah
you'll lose them but you'll get them
back like the next day it's the people
who try and save them who want to do a
little more who want to experiment it's
the people who aren't going to swim in
them which is who they're trying to stop
are going to be the most annoyed you'll
always get them back but the people who
finally started to save a little bit up
now you're like now i'm capped that just
annoys the middle person so it's
bungie's anti-capitalist message you
know there's got to be a limit on how
many how much you can you can own you
know what i mean it's really
it's really a problem in this destiny
yeah it is a problem all right so the
other pieces i want to read this out so
you guys can hear it one of these is
going to make travis's head explode and
then come back to normal our initial
goals for these currencies was to
sustain the interest in non-crafted
weapon drops which
picture a funnel web
and to retain the chase of weapons with
well-rolled perks in a post-crafting
destiny 2. they've said eventually
you're gonna have so many crafted
weapons i feel like that is a
short-sighted goal but that's just my
opinion the desire was that the player
would continually chase for combinations
such as subsistence rampage picture
funnel web to funnel their crafting
progression through deep sight weapon
completion while not the only reason
we're removing the specific currencies
there are two design changes pre-launch
which made the elements ineffectual
we had a currency this is what honestly
i think a lot of people had in their
head myself at least this is how i
thought crafting was going to work they
initially had a currency
per trade perk to craft rampage you
needed a weapon with rampage almost like
there was a rampage currency however due
to technical limitations and usability
issues too many currencies to track for
example
we opted to heavily simplify the element
currencies to the handful we shipped
this unfortunately resulted in a
decreased interest in chasing a specific
trait ascendant alloys and exotic
crafting materials that can be found
through high-end content we just lost
travis if you guys are on audio he's
gone
he's pacing back and forth right now
he's lost his mind this this is a
synthetic who sent the weave rant
inbound
level the exotic crafting material that
can be found through high-end content
purchase from rule made the remaining
condensed elements obsolete the
ascendant alloy currency was added after
they contents the elements and we were
unable to resolve the experiential
issues between these two currencies
prior to launch they literally knew it
was broken they have had a crazier
system in mind
that didn't work they tried to simplify
it then they put the ascendant alloy in
there that may and then the grind got
different it launched in such a
like odd state
that they they knew this was coming
early
so
one of my questions why the caps if you
already know it's just kind of weird and
broken two you know the element like why
even cap it now at all
because it's going away at the end of
it's gonna be literally deprecated like
iron banner token season 17 no more
legendary elements
yeah uh and then they said since launch
we've also been watching the player
conversation keep tabs on back in data
uh they're also looking at looking to
add more player control over deep sight
weapon unlocking of weapon patterns
because that rng is killer
continuing to monitor deep sight weapons
stockpiling because people's vaults are
now filling up with red weapons because
you have capacity caps it's like you
have the answer right here oh no people
are stockpiling caps up done solved it's
not hard as well as the resonant alloy
acquisition rates and behavior
uh we're also discussing feedback around
reshaping costs for those who wish to
experiment more frequently with their
trade selections no one is going to
spend to send an alloy to experiment
back does this feel good how does this
one how's this enhanced one fit you just
spent like
10 000
materials just to try and experiment now
you're broke and you can't even pick
so that's everything uh you can tell my
tone but i want to get granddad's
thoughts on this one for no actually i
gotta go travis green i'm sorry we gotta
get travis because he just had an
out-of-body experience
so
guys okay i need someone new rad or rook
or someone to go back into the archives
of the last word and find the episode
where we talked about crafting and my
fears about the currencies that they
were adding because in that episode i
specifically mentioned that i don't
think it's out of the realm of
possibility that there is a currency for
every perk and that we're looking at 40
new currencies and everyone on the panel
called me insane they were like there's
no way that'll ever happen they wouldn't
even consider it they're not that crazy
and this just goes to show you guys do
not underestimate these people they have
a problem they are they are addicted to
adding currencies to this game and there
is no limits to the levels that they
will go to to just destroy your brain
and and just make your inventory
overloaded and and we were that close we
were that close to being there and i
mean we got six which is way too many
they immediately realized that but the
fact that they even considered a version
where there's a currency for every perk
should scare the crap out of every
destiny player ever because this is
that is unbelievable guys it's
unbelievable and
go find that episode i want you to find
that episode because it needs to be
captured forever i cannot believe this
the classic line
is because the game limited them from
doing it they were talking about
limitations yeah that's the only reason
if they had their way
that sony money that they're getting
might enable them to add thousands of
currencies to their game guys that that
is what you're looking down the barrel
of thank god for technical limitations
thank god for them i cannot believe it
that's the only reason
it's uh it's unbelievable
yeah there should be one currency there
should be one crafting currency that's
it it should be
gun materials or whatever weapon
materials that they had for the gunsmith
it should have been something like that
my god
yeah this is nuts the thing about it too
is besides this
like we still have the issue with with
the the the caps on materials right it
still didn't completely go away and then
my thing is that the elephant in the
room that they not even mentioned it is
my biggest question because i feel this
whole thing is a hustle on a low and i'm
gonna tell you why
these enhanced perks is a straight
hustle
y'all seeing the benefit of these perks
the 0.2 more percentage faster or auto
loading holster
what i am not spending all these alloys
for 0.2
extra percent like i want some beefy
results if i'm gonna do this leveling
then they want you to level up the gun
and grind like come on if you're gonna
it always comes down to the juice and
the squeeze like you have to make this
a little bit more beneficial for this
all this is cool this is cute what you
think you're doing here but we know like
travis said this is due to limitations
in the game as opposed to you truly
trying to make the player experience
easier this is where like when you get
into those enhanced perks i don't care
if you slap two combatants so it doesn't
include guardians on everything and make
it a little extra busted if you're gonna
spin the currency but as you said
there's only the only one adaptive
munitions seems more worthwhile because
it really takes the multiplier against
the like wrong type of shield you build
that multiplier up very quickly that's
one of the few that like makes a
substantial difference in the amount of
damage you output but yeah most of these
are like here's the enhanced thing also
gives you a little stability or a little
reload speed and you're like i'm
spending this ascendant alloy that i can
go farm hard missions or
put six people together for a wellspring
for
and then what bugs me the most about all
of this granddad i swear you'll get to
talk in a second sorry we're on sorry
good day we did this
pent up frustration great yeah you gotta
let us have to get this the last thing
they get to is the fact that
the reshaping costs if you're gonna put
2000 neutral element
and whatever else it costs to go with it
plus the alloy into
say
enhanced archer's tempo and you're like
but i want to switch but but if i move
off of it i can't switch back i've
bought the currency i bought it already
you would literally have to buy it again
just to experience it that has to change
for the long term it needs to be a
permanent if you eventually you should
be able to unlock every perk yeah you
could go back to the relic and change
the perks but if you buy them once
should stick anyways granddad uh what
are your thoughts on crafting yes as a
whole because
yeah hit us hit us with the knowledge
crafting as a whole i think it's i mean
i'm enjoying it and i think it's a good
addition
but
i think they enhanced these enhanced
perks i on the morning of the raid of
the day one raid the morning of the raid
i decided that i wanted uh
enhanced ambitious
enhanced ambitious assassin
and uh enhanced lasting impression on
another on that palmyra rocket launcher
oh yeah so
so i went into shirochi with me rocket
launcher and leveled it up from zero to
twenty yeah so i spent like three hours
into in sure okay thanks a minute but
i thought that if i had i thought he was
gonna put basically enhanced ambitious
assassin and this is
looking back now there's some stupidest
thing this it was going to put three
in the tube that'd be great
yeah enhanced it's going to be better
yeah he's going to put three it doesn't
do anything it just it gives it a little
bit of a
little bit of a
uh
nothing
it does uh hardly anything i think it's
more more velocity or something like
that
it doesn't give you an extra one which
you would think enhanced ambitious
assassin call me old-fashioned
call your old friend
i would have thought it'd be an enhanced
version of that
it's so weird that you would think that
by the wording saying
enhanced ambitious assassin like it
would change
that perk
oh yes you don't know oh it gives you
velocity on your
yep no you're not wrong so anyway go
ahead
that assassin is not ambitious at all i
would say that is
just
pretty happy with his lot in life
[Laughter]
i'm happy for him
he's around his level he's found his
level
so again
it should have been having a little bit
more of a rest you know to get ready for
the heart slugger
uh i just thought you know what i'm just
gonna i'm gonna google it just uh before
i spend all this stuff i'm gonna google
it and it came up pages
ambi and enhanced ambitious assassin
does nothing blah blah blah
i looked at the screen oh my god oh my
god
so i went with uh
i went with auto loading and
i think i went we've also loaded an
enhanced explosive light in the end
which is fine but
another thing that bugs me as well is
that you can't in game you can't see how
much
how much
of each of the sale you've got easily
without you know
finding the gold
and then uh the cap on resident uh ally
as well oh yeah i don't get it's just
caps caps caps it's just
annoying yeah so
yeah that's my take on it i think the
enhanced stuff does need i think some
some of it is
he's all right but i think he need it
needs to be explained better what it
does
and uh
it needs to be more enhanced yeah
it needs to actually be enhanced
enhanced better yeah
it needs to live up to the name enhanced
not tweaked
yeah and another thing is i went into uh
witch queen with
i had 300 spare slots in my vault and
that's the best it's ever been if you
ask anyone who comes into my stream or
he knows me i was always at around
490 because i'd keep uh
i'd basically keep exotics or master
works from collections to save ascendant
shards which i was never going to use
but i just felt like i didn't want to
that's how what i was getting out of
gm's was to film me follow up with
exotics uh so i got rid of all them and
i got into a nice nice 300 300 uh
spaces i'm now at 499. because i've just
got a load of red weapons yeah yeah of
course
it literally made the vault situation
worse
because i i literally in good faith even
though i know i'm not going to grind out
the weapons when i get them i literally
just throw them in the vault because
it's just taking up space you know what
i mean and i also have a problem to to
what granddad said like
leveling up these i won't give the the
heavy weapons seem to be a little
quicker but to get down i mean heavy
weapons
about the only way it's reasonable but
otherwise they're slow because it's like
200 kills
or activities work too but yeah like
what a sniper bra
like come on like it's really painful
and then to get the point two percent
content version of these parts like
nah
like nah
he said it best when the first you know
we we first started messing around with
it this is literally the beta version of
this thing like we are not yeah we are
not even at 1.0 yet we we're we're still
figuring it out what you think oh
here's the thing here's the thing i i
agree with you but i feel like the one
just because it's the 1.0 doesn't mean
it's going to get better i mean we just
learned that a bungie had their way
there would be a different currency for
every damn perk and you guys are saying
oh yeah well they'll prove it make it
better it's like will they dude imagine
if if bungie were in charge of the u.s
economy oh you want to buy millions
you you want to you want to buy some
milk you got to spend milk bucks on that
specific currency for that oh you you
want to you want to buy a car yeah you
got to spend those those car dollars
that we made that specific currency like
it just
it's it's so
concerning that i'm just i'm i i don't
know if it's going to get better i mean
i'm really glad that they're getting rid
of the other currencies but part of me
is like well we'll get rid of the other
currencies until we you know that that
new engine comes along yeah they get 40
currencies you know i'm like what what
are they gonna do i don't i don't i
don't trust them now you have a new page
on your inventory you hit tab like go to
the next page and it's just a wall of
currency numbers and you're like oh god
what have i done
yeah no the current the currency system
system's gonna have an a through z tab
and you're gonna have to filter by you
know you might be able to look it in
game you're gonna have all
these yeah
so yeah crafting while i like the idea
of unlocking a pattern
spending time with a weapon
which i don't love the spending time
with the junk perks
because then i know i got to spend my
junk perk time with like zero to at
least about 12 or 13
so i can get the perks that i want
because i don't want to spend it once
then be like well i know i really want
the 13 per cause they put the good ones
at the end of course so somewhere
anywhere between 13 and 16 you're gonna
spend time with the weapon that doesn't
feel great i spent a lot of time with a
really really crappy sidearm
now that i finally got it and i may just
put it in my vault but that's
that's
i i get why that's there and like i
don't i don't quite know how to balance
that it's like that's not really my big
issue because eventually i can build
like
what you want
from
season of the risen with successful
warm-up and archer's tempo and when that
thing starts lining up precision hits
and kills it fires faster than a bow
should and i love it and it is amazing
and you i could also switch to adaptive
munitions like those are really cool
things
so many pieces around this system
are convoluted confusing grinding time
cons and it's just like that's it is
destiny and we know the grind is gonna
be there but
yeah the fact that travis was
speculating something that could have
been so much worse
and he was right
yeah he was right about that and then
and then the fact that now okay now you
have only neutral ellen but you only
have so much but you're still only going
to get this much you still
there's still there's a lot of work that
needs done it feels like but yeah the
fact that travis was as close as he was
to i was like hey there's only like six
and you're like oh there's going to be
more there could have been so many more
it is it is yeah there could have been
rampage element golden tricorn element
so
many perks um that would have been chaos
that would have been just that would
have been a 7 out of 10 for my gm i
think
so they are going to continue to monitor
feedback but
this is probably going to be one of
those things that feels
finely reasonable and lightfall is a
hunch i like the idea of the god rules
um being attainable but it is the
process around it definitely needs yeah
because somebody the one part i was
thinking about as i was recording my
little video over this
they're looking to try and make the
control over deep sight weapons and
unlocking patterns and i just picture
sees another risen take somebody who
doesn't get to play that often not any
of us on this podcast or half the people
watching the show somebody gets to play
a few hours on a weekend and they get to
play the season of the risen story and
then they're gonna kind of tune in and
work on unlocking the war table but they
play a little bit each weekend there is
a perk on week four now that your first
weapon focus
is gonna be a deep sight
you get one a week that's a guarantee so
take that person who logs in
maybe they get the one where you kill
the light uh light hoarders so you get
three per battleground they log in they
do three battlegrounds they do a couple
other things over the course of the
remainder of this season
they could get what i'm guessing like
say 11 weapons that have a pattern
i know the pulse rifle takes five i know
the machine gun takes five and that's
ten
and you would get one more pattern you
could literally that casual person
depending on how much they play
could maybe unlock half of the season
risen weapons during the season
for the casual player that sounds awful
mm-hmm
so
and then you still gotta spend the time
with it unlock it and then put the
amount of hours into upgrading the
weapon to see all the perks that
person's gonna get to enjoy their
peace of mind pulse rifle in season 18.
yeah yeah
but is that not
i can't i get what you're saying but is
that not the is that not fair
no it's like the people who the people
who don't play the game as much don't
don't get as much of the good stuff and
believe me from my side i'm sitting
there going i i'm four weeks in i've
played a lot i haven't even got i've
unlocked two of the season risen weapons
and i have almost reset my risen or the
silence battlegrounds i'm almost on my
second reset
so i know how much time i've put in
wow i've been i'll do like if i see
psychogenic intel full i'll go do a
risen i'll do a go one or two
battlegrounds dump it out then i'll do
trials or i'll do a wellspring because
i've been farming a bunch of other stuff
i was like
and again yeah for the hardcore players
can they grind it out absolutely and for
the casual player is it a long-term
grind sure
but there's a point where the long-term
grind feels unattainable
right to where at that point it's it is
a little defeating we say the person is
going to walk away after four weeks if
they want to and then if they tune in or
if they play on a casual basis they
spread that story out a little farther
there there needs to be a balance i feel
like the the long-term incentive grind
is too far for that casual player
right and yeah it would go faster for
some of us crazy people who grind but
we're always going to burn through stuff
too fast but for yeah like half of the
player base that's the point where i
feel like they've set the bar
too
too far
i think to be reasonable long term is
one thing but i think it is too far to
say in the middle of season 17 i finally
got some my season risen weapons because
a lot of people as soon as that new
season comes out the psyops
battlegrounds is no longer going to be
powerfuls no long and it's it's then
you're going back into the old stuff
which is
a thing so it's it's
that's just my opinion but i was just
thinking about that one
yeah but at least uh the casuals as we
as we call them at least they're going
to get the sherpa emblem just by doing
one raid haven't seen that yes
that's given to everybody now
i saw that and i was even thinking about
people like you
man oh there's a lot of like sherpas
that we've actually had come through and
all of those that they enjoy that
and you guys have the prestige of doing
that now you're like well it was kind of
bugged so everybody gets it and you're
going yeah you can't like fix it later
and look at the stats
no
so but if we moan about it that makes us
elitist so
yeah no no no
you don't have to you're allowed
you play the game too much to complain
granddad sorry about that yeah yeah
that's the last point i wanted to say
and i i do agree with granddad as far as
the grind and grind to me the value is
only in grinding for the perk
combination that you want because it as
far as the enhancement part we all agree
that that's kind of a joke but the thing
that's really really
egregious for the new player is the
expense
let's say if you're a new player and you
truly want to embrace crafting right
most new players don't have 400
legendary shots to go talk to
you know what i'm saying
to get like the sourcing and where you
can get it and it's just not a new light
friendly system and it's for us that's
grinding we're barely getting enough of
the patterns enough as it is right so
that's real it's really off-putting to a
duplicate they've they've got to do a
better job of figuring that part out so
at least they can start the grind right
they could they have to cost the entry
to if they wanted to experiment a little
bit yeah yeah yeah that's a random thing
shout out to mri gamer uh have you
talked about the frustration of the
exotic glaive grind for other classes so
you once you finish your
evidence board and you craft your first
one it takes like five seconds
you have to live in wellspring on like a
.01 chance drop rate to get the other
class
patterns
to just drop
now i actually got the warlock one
randomly and all of this other stuff i
was doing i may never see the hunter one
i don't know yeah but that is
you you pick one and then the other two
now become the like the worst rng you
could have and it's just yeah
that's going to burn you out on the
activity unfortunately
i'm the terrible as well
yeah all the exotic lights are not worth
it they are terrible
they are just not worth it yeah you get
like a baby bubble without the fun with
mine
yeah the babe the baby bubble was fun
but i was i was thinking about like is
there a use case for this in any mode
where it would actually be good and also
they've been slowly
yeah so slow
yeah yeah yeah and remember the warlock
one is the only one i can see doing
something because you could literally
plop down a little healing turret that's
like sending out healing little bubbles
like the noble rounds that's the only
one i could see because you could drop
it
it's not so small you can barely stand
in it yourself and then you get one
lightning attack as a hunter like that
those two are
those need buff later on or they were
just basically a joke so yeah they're
not worth grinding for on top of it but
if you do ever get it you're like cool
throw that in the vault
yeah
only other things they have they are
known issues and there's only just a few
i want to mention
armor offered by vendors and including
zur thank god this will get is is low
stat rolls they're like collections and
they're all the same so at some point
zero will get back to at least having a
chance at some decent stuff so that is
good
um they said players who go flawless in
trials aren't receiving post-win weapons
and rewards that's major so be careful
if you have bad drops in there mementos
are not dropping in trials
totally forgot that was a thing i
thought they were also supposed to drop
from the raid
or is the momentum going to be
what you get that's like the gambit
memento where if you level it up like 30
you get the custom shader
oh okay maybe i've had one of them yeah
it was like i've ever done it seven
times i haven't seen one yet so
um
yeah yeah i've
i've done the raid what 25 26 times
that plays you go flawless thing a
couple of friends of mine were playing
on a seven win flawless card and weren't
getting the uh
you know the extra uh i don't know oh
wow yeah so i don't know if that's that
could be part of it so yeah even trials
trials was not on this week and they are
working on some of these in hopefully a
future patch but those were just a
couple i wanted to shout out but that's
the most stuff from the quad but the
crafting i know we went off on a tangent
there but that was the big thing
um
is there anything else you guys want to
talk about in the world of destiny
because i want to touch on basically one
other completely separate topic before
we go
i'm good
no just i'd like to register my
displeasure everyone getting that emblem
once again
[Music]
i feel you i feel you on that one as
they're
raiders as a true rage sherpa
yeah the fact that everybody gets that
one that's yeah that's not great thank
you as long as it's been lodged
my complaint's been launched thank you
uh the last thing and this is completely
different so the destiny people can
maybe bail but
anybody watch the harry potter thing
today
yeah
anybody a harry potter fan in here i
don't think cog is because listen to you
and maddie both be like i don't care
i don't care but that look i can't look
amazing
yeah i was gonna say it doesn't look
amazing yeah it does actually look
i was blown away by how much was in that
thing did you see it granddad are you
busy
no wha what is that so it's the harry
potter wizarding world it's hogwarts
legacy it's a single player action rpg
built in the harry potter world and it's
like takes place in what is like 1890s
so it's before any of the stories we've
seen in the movies i don't do do you
like the movies or the universe or
anything or
i've never seen a harry potter movie
okay
in fairness
well it looks like a really cool action
rpg with more with the ladies
come on
you're like yeah
[Laughter]
you weren't with the ladies because you
were with the lady you're so dedicated
just like
you're a one-woman man you know what i
mean i'm about to play elden ring
tomorrow and cheat on my mistress yeah
she got my mistress that's like next
level
all i'm saying is granddad you can't tie
him down he was out there just you know
he was multi-classing
yeah
anyway
i just wanted to say that i had i knew i
had very low expectations for what this
game could be
and it literally blew me away on every
front the fact that you've got going to
class getting sorted you've got the
potions you're going to have defense of
the dark arts then you've got wiz combat
on the grounds and
i
like this is a day one play for me on
the holidays this just jumped way up the
charts for me because it's holiday of
2022 and honestly i don't expect god of
war making it this this time and until i
see more on starfield that's still a big
question mark too i just saw a 14-minute
video on hogwarts and i'm going yeah
it honestly i'm really excited about it
now and it's gonna i feel like
i'm not gonna put on the level of
witcher because i've never played the
thing but as much as they showed and as
much was built out i feel like it could
be like a 100 hour rpg for a single
player it looks
absolutely massive travis what are your
thoughts since i know you saw it
yeah yeah uh
like i think the rest of the panel i'm
not really a harry potter guy i i
remember harry potter the fad you know
when i was a kid it was it was
definitely like coming up but i was
already reading lord of the rings when
harry potter happened i was just a
little bit more advanced in my reading
and i remember just like looking at the
harry potter books and being like ah
these are kid books you know like i'm
reading i'm reading about all this dope
like lord of the rings super heavy stuff
and harry potter's kind of a little bit
more light-hearted so
um
but but that said the
you know the the world is is very well
built it's perfect for an rpg i think
any any time where you're in school and
you also have to you know do an
adventure is is kind of a dope format um
and uh
what they showed is really cool i do
have some stuff i'm worried about combat
to me looked a little
yeah right like it's it's definitely
it's definitely harry pottery but it
looks a little e and also the broom
flying i thought looked really bad in
terms of especially the animation like
the cloaks weren't moving at all and
stuff like that so you know they've
still got like what seven months to work
on the game i'm sure it'll be more
polished but i i expected this game was
gonna be good
when our friend chandler i think you
know him too you bought this but uh
chandler uh the guy who used to be the
editor-in-chief for playstation
lifestyle magazine uh yeah he absolutely
looked up yeah
yeah he and i um became really good
friends because we were always covering
destiny together and we met at bungie
headquarters and then every couple
months we would go back to bungie
headquarters to see what the next thing
was and it was like a reunion it was
like oh i'm gonna get to see chandler
again and we like hung out all the time
we're like legit friends and we met
through destiny in person at bungie
headquarters so
um as soon as i saw he quit his cushy
editor-in-chief uh job to go uh work for
this game i was like this game is going
to be something special because he uh he
wouldn't he wouldn't have given that up
for nothing so uh super cool guy and uh
yeah i'm i'm i'm actually excited for
this game even though
uh even though it's um you know not
really my favorite world you know harry
potter whatever and i will say this the
people who are harry potter fans oh
they're exploding
with my girlfriend and she was like
jumping up and down and all the animal
petting and the fact that you get to
choose your choose your school like all
that stuff
so yeah it's uh they're dead they
definitely know their audience super
well yeah i can tell that the people
making it are fans yeah i think that's
that's what you saw in the stuff
afterwards
is the people making the game they're
like for all the fans out there who love
the series were those same people and we
made a game and we put every and it
looks like they just wanted to make it
for those people
and i'm just really excited so that was
just like a random thing i wanted to say
at the end granddad if you're
you don't play other things so yeah no
worries
yeah just destiny just tested it i'm
afraid you weren't
marbles on stream on occasion yeah i've
seen that there you go
got those call outs
yeah
well that was pretty much all i've got
um
granddad thank you so much for coming on
the show it was an absolute pleasure and
so
i think my two co-hosts enjoyed it even
more just because the intro i don't know
if i've seen their lives light up and
talking about like the graffiti and
hip-hop and everything it was
it was good times for everybody on the
show and i want to thank you as an
absolute pleasure having you on tonight
and at this point um for anybody who
hears the show now later or in the
future um where can they find you what
can they find you doing and
you know how can they support you and
all those types of things the floor is
yours
thank you you can find me daily apart
from mondays on
twitch.tv forward slash granddad gaming
underscore
uh you can find me doing raid helps and
gm helps all pve and game activity
whilst having
some good laughs dancing and
impersonating celebrities thank you
yes
love it man love it man great great
guests
love the stories the hip-hop touches so
you talking real b-boy real essence real
core stuff so
that's the era man and it's good to hear
you know people keeping that alive love
the content love the takes keep up the
work man it's been really cool it's just
cool to see someone you know what i'm
saying from the generation just holding
it down like you know yeah i love that
kind of stuff you were good people
jarvis the homie
i love those guys so salute to the team
as well but yeah great great guess
yeah thank you all
trav what's going on with you
yeah um you can you can follow me on
twitter at ty guy travis or read my
articles reviews previews at ign.com um
my review of the witch queen is live my
next review is
uh tiny tina's wonderlands which will be
up on wednesday um and uh yeah if you if
you care about gaming industry news i do
a show every sunday morning called
bitcast
um uh that that you can find uh at
season gaming um
yeah it's been a super fun week i'm
really excited to
see where destiny goes and have 11 weeks
of it's also just been a crazy week in
general i don't know did you have you
guys been reading the news like uh
apparently we're getting rid of daylight
saving time finally yeah yeah
huge it's going to be uh 2023 apparently
the winter in wisconsin is going to be
really bad but we we've been doing this
real weird thing for a number of years
like 60 years and we're finally going
back to normal um so anyway uh
interesting stuff but it's an exciting
time to be a destiny fan and uh gamer in
general so how about you cog what do you
got going on uh saving any more uh
children
i think he's got a spicy defining duke
you guys need to go get on that uh last
word patreon because that one yeah i
want to hear this talk about perfect the
other topic i wanted to talk about yeah
perfect darks but a little spicy so go
listen yeah yeah yeah yeah great great
conversation great halo conversation on
ultimate great uh perfect dog comes back
maddie kind of getting pocket and it's
been it's been fun so get a chance to
check it out when you when you get a
chance or if you don't you don't want to
pay that to patreon on on demand you
just wait till sunday you know it's 3.99
but uh nice it's been cool so go check
that out with defining getting an iron
lord podcast every sunday is the
lawrence day 1 p.m eastern with the
homies king addicts off just taking it
back to the essence man so it's going to
be fun and yeah that's been pretty much
it man just been grinding doing my thing
and e what's been going on with you now
that you free of destiny uh well i mean
i'm still going to be covering destiny
and making videos on it but i as i said
tomorrow after myself video probably
early afternoon after i get a little
lunch uh elden ring until i sleep and
then elden ring pretty much all day
saturday so
i'm excited to get lost in that one
that's going to be a lot of my varieties
and i'm working on
possibly
second channel to upload all of that
play through because
messing with the algorithm on youtube is
already just a dance and with danger as
it is in the first place
and that would just like be weird so if
i do want to work on just kind of maybe
an abontous plays channel so my gameplay
can potentially go up there as an
alternative so
trying to spread a little more and have
a place to put it
but i am no as a as a fellow blind elton
ring runner if you uh if you need any
like
tips or hints without spoiling things oh
i'm your guy you know i've got yeah
finally um
one person in chat black wings he's
usually in here but i'm sure he'll catch
this later he said somehow he's like i
didn't buy it there's no charge on my
credit card but eldering is now on my
xbox
i don't know how it happened to him but
i was like no i told him i was like play
it and he he's it's his first souls game
and he already can't be quiet about it
so
[Laughter]
game pass works in mysterious ways yeah
like he tripped into some lottery fell
onto him but yeah
but again i want to thank you granddad
for coming in it was an absolute
pleasure i've been enjoying your content
the emotes from new red and rook and
there's some the dancing emote lives in
my channel a lot as well so you are you
are enjoyed many places with those
wonderful i got to work on some animated
emotes because yours are yours is solid
for sure
um but for this episode it has been an
absolute wonder having you on chat you
guys have been absolutely on fire
tonight thank you guys so so much
and for everybody in here episode number
189 march 17th for this episode it has
been
the last word